Boom,
and we're live.
How are you doing?
Are Our.
A lot of stuff is going on
stuff.
Alana,
since your settlement.
Jamie and I were hoping that you would
come in with one of those Paul Wall
grills,
like diamonds on it and maybe some furs.
Yeah,
up in a cadillac.
Unfortunately it it's enough money to
make a difference,
but it's not enough money to do no
longer have to think about such things
so you can temporarily ball though if
you were irresponsible and you didn't
have a family.
If I didn't have a family,
you get crazy for a couple of months.
As it happens.
It gives us a room to think about how to
replace our incomes.
We have about two years at our current
rate of.
Of burning to keep the family.
Yeah.
People just.
So this is a standalone podcast so
people can kind of.
What you need to do,
if you're really interested in this,
it really interested is google,
Bret Weinstein and you will get the full
story from beginning to end with
evergreen state college where I'll just
give you the short version of it.
There was a bunch of what you would
kindly call social active people,
social justice warriors,
people who there's a movement going on
in this country and it's very aggressive
and one of the things that they wanted
to do is they wanted to have a day where
a,
all white people stayed home.
You thought that was racist.
They thought you were racist for saying
that was racist.
And um,
they decided to literally take over the
college for a short period of time.
The dust settled,
you just got a big fat settlement,
you're out of there.
And so,
uh,
and then the woman who was kind of at
the head of it,
she got a nice little chunk of change
to,
which I thought was quite odd.
College settled with her,
even though it was quite clear,
she had no legal case.
So there's a bit of a mystery about why
they would have paid her to resign,
when in fact they could have just stood
their ground.
She could have probably become the
president of the college if she wanted
to.
The way that guy had responded to the
students when they told him to put his
hands down because he was being
threatening,
and then he put his hands up.
He's talking them and using hand
gestures and they're like,
put your hands down,
you're threatening us with
microaggressions,
puts his hands down.
They all started laughing,
which just tells you everything about
what their intent was,
what was really going on there and.
But after I saw that,
I'm like,
she could have been the president.
They should've just had herbie
president.
The whole things.
It was a kangaroo court was mockery
thing was absurd.
I will say I've.
It's very hard to get the story right in
any sort of short synopsis and so for
anybody who really wants,
it's not even complete,
but heather and I,
my wife Heather was also a professor at
evergreen and we wrote a more complete
version of the story that people to see
how the internal politics of the college
played out into what they ultimately saw
on youtube.
So that's in the Washington examiner a
last Tuesday.
I read that and it's
deeply disturbing.
It's,
but it's not.
If you've been paying attention and you
know you and I and Jordan Peterson and
boy,
a bunch of people have tried to figure
out what's going on today,
like why has this movement become so
aggressive and so not just aggressive
but observed not.
It's not logical like the way they're
approaching things is from this very
strange entitled and just oddly
fanatical way.
You want to be careful not to mix what
they say with what they're actually up
to because what they say is very
confusing.
If it can't be parsed logically,
there's so many contradictions so close
to the surface that one has the sense
that they are deeply confused and some
of them are,
but there is also a strategic movement
under the surface which we can't listen
into directly and it is more
sophisticated than we think.
In other words,
it is managing to wield power in spite
of the fact that it's explanation for
why it is entitled to wield power
doesn't make any sense.
What do you think the underlying
motivation is like?
What is their or their.
At least their underlying
plan?
I would say we have to be careful there
are a lot of people who go along with it
who I would argue are tools of the
movement and they are doing it's bidding
without understanding the objective,
but the prime movers are quite clearly
interested in taking power.
They want power,
they have a superficial rationalization
for why they are entitled to power and
they are wielding weaponized stigma as a
mechanism for gaining.
So you said that Nyeema could have
become the president of the college.
I don't know whether she could have.
It would have been a very unusual path,
but I do know that for more than a year
I watched people unable to resist
anything.
She said.
Even people who knew better would in
faculty meetings,
they would reflectively thank her for
anything she said no matter how absurd
it was.
And that was clearly a sort of,
you know,
as the equivalent of a wolves bearing
their juggler was don't hurt me.
I'm with you.
Don't hurt me.
And so that kind of power is something
that a person who is cynical enough to,
uh,
to wield stigma to get it might cover
it.
And so anyway,
I think there's a small number of people
who really do know what they're doing
and their point is we can wipe many of
the obstacles to our having power off
the map by throwing accusations at them
that they cannot resist.
Yeah.
The big accusation is racism.
That that's always the big one.
That's one you never want to have thrown
your way if you are deemed a racist.
It's like it's akin to being deemed a
rapist,
even if it's a false charge.
Like,
boy,
most people are going to hear the first
statement before they ever look into the
possibility that you'd been exonerated.
It's you being called a racist is a
very,
very dangerous thing in today's society.
It's a very dangerous thing.
I do think it's important that we not do
their bidding by inflating that danger
beyond what it actually is.
So I do,
we will never know for sure what the
trajectory would have been absent what
happened at Evergreen.
But I do think standing up to the mom at
Evergreen and just saying,
frankly,
no,
I'm not a racist.
You're asking really important
for people that don't know you.
You are a very progressive guy.
You're.
You're very left wing,
very left leaning.
You're.
You're not in any way,
shape or form a conservative and so this
like this is,
this is the left eating itself.
It is the left eating itself,
but I was also in the lucky position of
being able to imagine what was going to
happen when that accusation broke and
knowing that there were so many people
who knew that that couldn't possibly be
right about me,
that I was going to survive it,
and it's not as if there aren't huge
numbers of people who still to this day
apparently believe I'm a racist,
in spite of the fact that nothing has
emerged in all of the time with all of
the incentive for somebody to bring
something forward that would suggest
that I have an issue with race somewhere
in my history.
It never emerged and so people do need
to understand that it is possible to
survive that accusation.
Well,
especially with your background though,
people don't know your background.
Was it at Yale that you had penn,
Penn to tell that story?
Sure,
sure.
I'll.
I'll do the quick and dirty version.
I'm cliff notes.
I was a freshman at Penn.
A friend of mine was rushing a
fraternity and the fraternity was
holding what they call it,
a mystery event and I wasn't rushing a
fraternity.
I wAsn't interested,
but he convinced me that I didn't have
anything to do that night and that I
should go with him and I did,
and after some relatively standard
fraternity shenanigans,
the event turned into one in which the
fraternity had hired prostitutes,
pro black prostitutes from the local
environment and the situation.
Penn is in a pretty rough neighborhood
and this was a pretty wealthy jewish
frat,
and so there was,
you know,
something a pretty unsettling about a
wealthy jewish frat,
hiring black prostitutes from the local
neighborhood to engage in what started
out to be a strip tease 'em.
As this thing began to unfold and I
realized I didn't have any interest in
being part of this event,
I made one of the bigger mistakes of my
life and I left the event,
but when my friend and other members of
the fraternity rolled into the dorm that
night and told me what happened,
I was absolutely appalled because what
had happened was the fraternity had
enacted a,
a,
a mock rape of these prostitutes using
cucumbers and ketchup and,
um,
the idea that there was anything
acceptable about a,
you know,
an organization that had special
privileges on the campus behaving this
way.
I couldn't get past it.
And so anyway,
I went to the paper and various things
unfolded.
the paper botched the story and made it
look like I was troubled by the fact
that there were strippers rather than
troubled by what actually had ended up
happening.
And,
uh,
I ended up writing an editorial for the,
for the paper and all hell broke loose.
Um,
there,
you know,
I got death threats.
the police started tracking phone
numbers on my phone to see who was
threatening me.
Ultimately,
there was a trial of the fraternity,
the college did not want to put the
fraternity on trial,
but ultimately public pressure forced
them to do it.
I testified at the trial,
although since I hadn't seen the thing
directly,
what I could say was limited,
but while I was in the witness room with
the other witnesses,
people who had rushed the fraternity but
had not pledged it,
uh,
the fraternity brothers,
including,
I believe the president came in to the
witness room and started bullyIng these
witnesses and coaching them on what they
should say in front of this,
uh,
this university panel.
Anyway,
ultimately the university was the
university through the frat off campus
for a year,
forbid them from pledging a class.
Um,
and,
uh,
anyway,
there's a lot more to the story.
I got an award from the national
organization for women actually for a,
I've,
I forgot their terminology,
but for basically for standing up,
for,
for women who needed to be defended or
something like that.
You,
you said you've made the biggest
mistake,
one of the biggest mistakes of your life
by leaving mean meaning that if you were
there you could have probably stopped it
or you could at least have known exactly
what was going on there.
No way I could've stopped it,
but I left because I didn't want to be
party to this event,
but sometime I think journalists know
this.
I was a freshman in college so I didn't
know it yet,
but journalists understand that
sometimes something horrifying happens
and the job that you are best positioned
to do is documenting it so that the
world can understand how such things
occur and do something about it and if I
had understood that that was probably my
highest and best use at that moment,
I would have stuck around and paid
attention to what had happened rather
than having to go through convincing the
world that something had happened,
which I had not directly seen.
Yeah,
I mean how could you have known there's
no.
I don't think it should be hard on
yourself at all.
You're 18,
right?
Exactly.
How could you have known?
How could you have known,
even if you were 30,
how could you have known what was going
to happen?
It looked like prostitutes and you're
like,
eh,
I don't want to be here.
See ya.
Exactly.
You didn't know there was going to be a
mock rape.
Right?
I couldn't have known,
but in any case,
in retrospect,
it was a mistake.
It's ah,
it's so crazy that they let groups of
kIds live in a house together and get
hammered when they don't even have their
frontal cortex develop yet manage all
living together,
feeding off of each other.
you have mob mentality.
All this diffusion of responsibility
because you have a large group of people
that's also like you and everybody's so
bananas that,
that is few incidents happen as they do.
I mean,
you would think that those things would
just be chaos the moment you opened up
the door to every frat house.
Yeah,
and you know there's more chaos than we
know because a lot of what takes place
we don't,
we don't fInd out about.
But it's a shame because one could take
the thing that drives people into those
organizations.
And one could use it to power something
that was useful and interesting and you
know,
really was deeply enriching and I know
how much flack am I going to take for
giving the fraternity system a hard tIme
on your podcast.
But plenty of people will tell me how
enriching their fraternity experience
was.
And you know,
even at penn there were a couple
fraternities that were,
I was,
as you can imagine,
hated throughout the fraternity system
at penn after I had come forward.
But there were two fraternities that
actually didn't hate me and we're
welcoming even in that climate.
So I don't want to portray them as a
monolith there or not.
But um,
but it does seem like a wasted
opportunity that,
that kind of energy that goes into
fraternity life could be directed to
something really amazing.
And it's a shame that it doesn't happen
more often.
Well,
I'm sure there's a lot of great
comradery and it's probably a lot of fun
to go through that experience together
with people that are your same age and
you're actually living in a house
together,
but just manage probably awesome fucking
adults in that room.
Something like that.
It seems like it just seems like just to
limit your liability.
Yep.
Right.
Without the 35 year olds running around
and going,
hey,
what are you doing over there?
My fire won't be able to put that out.
Adult like that one on fire,
just,
I dunno.
Just crazy.
So that's your,
your situation.
So anybody that would think of you as a
conservative or a racist,
it's like,
it's clearly the evidence points to the
contrary.
Well,
I,
you know,
this issue of conservatism is one that I
would like to also get right.
and I'm not sure I ever say this in a
way that people know what I'm talking
about,
but I'm,
I'm very progressive,
but I'm very progressive because I live
in a world that's really screwed up.
And so the idea that we have to make
some progress seems just transparently
correct me.
um,
I would like to live in a world that
is so well structured that I could be a
conservative and I don't mean a
conservative in the sense that the
ideological sense,
I mean I would like to be in a world
where tinkering with it stood a better
chance of making it worse,
um,
and was unnecessary and so that,
that would,
that would turn me into a conservative
because it would be the right thing to
be in a proper analysis would tell you
this is the time to conserve the
structure rather than change it.
But in this world,
yeah,
it turns out I'm a,
I'm a progressive.
And the events that people keep telling
me that they were sure I'm now at a
closet conservative,
that the,
what I faced must have turned me against
the left.
And that's not at all what happened.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
I've,
I've faced out myself that people say,
oh,
you're going to turn more conservative
with all this.
No,
I'm just more resentful of these fake
progressive movement that,
like you said,
has ulterior motives.
There's,
there's more to it.
It's and it's not.
It's not accurate.
Like the portrayals of humans in in
these movements are not accurate.
It's not.
I don't think it's healthy.
I don't think it's normal and I think
there's a lot of.
The game of capitalism is a very
confusing one and there's certainly
certainly some very evil aspects to it.
Right,
but the idea that the answer is marxism
seems to me to be just as just as poorly
thought out it.
It's,
it's at least as poorly thought out
marxism.
The flaw is more obvious.
I think the flaw is what we in biology
would call group selection.
The belief that if we just all row in
the same direction,
we'll get somewhere.
Marvelous,
and that's true,
that if we did all row in the same
direction we would,
but there's a very good game theoretic
reason that that can't be.
Yeah.
That as soon as you have everybody
rowing in the same direction,
then the wind goes to the person who
figures out how not to row and gets the
benefit of everybody else's rowing in
that direction while they sweep in the
prophets and so that tears apart
anything structured.
The way communism is structured.
Yeah,
that's conveniently ignored.
I think I really have always believed
that competition is good and it's
because I've been involved in
competition my whole life and I think it
helps you understand yourself.
You're competing against other people,
but ultimately you're really competing
against yourself because you're trying
to better yourself and I believe that
that's the argument for getting children
involved in athletics or games or
something that's very difficult to do.
Whether it's chess or pool or something.
I think things that are hard to do are
good for you.
Competing is good for you because it
teaches you about focus and discipline
and understanding that there is.
You can reap the rewards of hard work
and you know,
obviously this can get distorted and you
can get these,
you know,
billionaire oligarchs who,
control vast amounts,
wealth and then they have
their family and everyone inherits it
and you have these fucking mutants that
are all inbred and they're all in the
same bloodline mean that's,
that's history,
right?
I mean that has taken place,
but I think that
we should work very hard for equality of
opportunity.
I think equality of oPportunity give
everybody a chance to play a game.
Everybody a chance to get into something
and,
and try to better themselves with some
endeavor and summit.
But whenever I hear equality of outcome,
that's when I put my foot down.
I'm like,
that doesn't it?
That's not real.
You can't say that because some people
work harder and if you have true
equality,
you're never going to have equality of
outcome.
Because true equality is.
I have friends that are brilliant,
that are fantastic human beings,
but they're essentially beach bums.
You know,
they did like kick back and relax and do
the minimal amount of work to get things
done.
and just enjoy life,
have a couple cocktails,
go to the beach,
have laughs with friends,
that's what they like to do.
And then I have other friends that want
to be,
you know,
world martial arts champions and that's,
you,
you have two different kinds of lives to
different thing to different types of
human beings.
That style of human one person is going
to be extremely satisfied with one life
and extremely dissatisfied with the
other life and you can interchange them
back and forth.
Well,
you said a bunch of things.
We could spend three hours unpacking
what you Just said.
Um,
let's say a number of things.
One,
equality of opportunity is something I
have yet to find the reasonable person
that does not agree on this point.
In principle,
lots of people will tell you it's not
worth the effort of trying to pursue it
because of the danger of what happens if
you do.
But nobody disagrees.
Nobody reasonable disagrees that it
would be desirable to have that equality
of outcome.
It's impossible.
If you pursue it,
you end up with a dystopia.
And even if it were possible,
it would not be desirable for the
reasons you point to about the benefits
of what you're calling competition.
And I would want to tear competition
into a couple different values.
There's true competition against
yourself.
You know,
you,
you're skiing down the slope and you're
paying attention to how you're doing and
you're trying to do it better than
you've done it before,
right?
Um,
and there's competition against others.
And the thing that unites those two
things is that the,
what you are trying to accomplish is
real.
It is the world telling you how
successful you are at something directly
rather than through some sort of social
channels,
some sort of reward handed to you or
some compliment given to you by
somebody.
and there's a tremendous danger in a
socially mediated world in which those
who are successful are successful
because some social thing has told them
that they are correct because you can be
dead wrong,
seem correct and move ahead in social
world.
Whereas if you're doing carpentry,
if you're in some sort of competition,
the nature of the beast is one that will
tell you when you've got it wrong and
therefore it will allow you to actually
improve your insight in whatever form
you have it.
So I'm a tremendous fan of the idea that
even if your world is largely socially
mediated,
you have to make sure that some part of
it isn't and you are confronting
something real enough to tell you when
you're confused so that you can learn
how not to be confused,
but there are people in this world that
do want to push towards an equality of
outcome and they.
They make it sound as if this is not
Just logical but ethical and possible
and the future and that you are on the
wrong side of history.
If you.
If you think that capitalism and
competition and all these things you
just talked about are good and that
really the best thing is to force people
to become some sort of utopian creature
that works together in unison and and
everybody is a egalitarian and there's
no need for feminism and men's rights.
Activists,
because everybody looks at everyone as
an equal.
Well,
there are two kinds of people who will
advocate for equality of outcome.
One kind of person who will is confused.
They don't understand what happens if
you go down this road and the other one
is cynical and they're using this as an
excuse to justify something that just so
happens to reward them,
but equality of opportunity isn't this
way.
It solves all of those problems.
Nobody believes that you're going to
have it ever realized in a perfect form.
There's always going to be bad luck.
That's going to reduce somebody's
opportunity,
which don't want is any systematic bias
in luck.
In other words,
we're all going to suffer some bad luck
and we'll all have some good luck and
some of those things will actually shape
the trajectory of our lives,
which you don't want is some population
that just so happens to suffer more than
its share of bad luck,
which is what we have now.
So there is there just something to
pursue here,
but we're so busy on this other
pointless conversation about equality of
outcome that we can't.
We can't get back to the thing that we
all agree on,
that's actually the right goal
and there's also some background chatter
that you'll get from the less less
thought out where the people are really
just upset that other people have more
and so it's is an uneducated,
not very well thought out perspective on
equality of outcome.
They are upset that someone else has
something and they're trying to somehow
or another diminish the effect of their
hard work and get something for
themselves.
Well,
you can imagine though,
so maybe we take a little digression
here.
My experience over the last six months
has done a bunch of things in my life.
One of them is it has put me in touch
with quite a number of black
conservatives,
which I must tell you this.
It has changed my understanding of the
world substantially because I used to.
I knew there were black conservatives
and I always thought,
are they confused?
Are they not understanding which side
they should be on and that is not.
That is not what's going on.
What is going on is that there is a
dialogue which I couldn't hear at least
which looks at the world.
You can view the unfairness in the world
two different ways.
You can look at it and you can say,
well,
they're structural unfairness in the
world and the cards that we in this
community are dealt are not fair.
We're not getting our share of the good
cards.
Or you can look at the world from the
point of view of personal responsibility
and you can say,
well,
it's kind of an academic question.
Whether the cArds you got were fair.
You should play them as best you can.
Give them what they are.
You're.
The thing that I didn't get was one has
almost no ability to address the
question of how the cards are dealt.
It's just not in.
It's not in the range of somebody.
An individual who discovers that the
cards are unfairly dealt,
can't do very much about that fact,
but that individual can do a hell of a
lot about their own position in the
world by recognizing that actually you,
uh,
especially if the cards are unfairly
dealt,
you need to play them very well and that
developing the skill to play them well
has the ability to overcome at least
some of the unfairness and how they're
dealt.
And so I have now listened In on this
commerce.
I've been invited into the conversation
amongst some of these black
conservatives and this is what,
what they are really saying is that
there is from the point of view of where
to put one's efforts dealing on the
personal responsibility side pays back
better,
which I don't think frees us in
civilization from addressing the
question of how the cards are dealt.
I think we should be focused on it,
but anyway,
it more or less solved the mystery in a
way that I thought was,
was quite fascinating.
And uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm heartened that,
that they were willing to invite me into
that conversation.
So I could hear it and finally figure
out what was what was going on.
So they advocate towards discipline and
personal responsibility as being core
tenants that you should reinforce.
Right?
And they are very sensitive to the issue
of what happens when you focus on the
unfairness of how the cards are dealt,
which is that,
you know,
what progressive's typically miss is
that it really does create a culture of
dependency if you focus on the fact that
the cards are unfairly dealt and that
that's why you're facing a disadvantage,
which is largely true.
Nonetheless,
it demotivates you from pursuing success
because you,
you,
you recognize that you're starting at a
disadvantage and that you know,
you're unlikely to win the game.
On the other hand,
the game is and what we think,
you know,
if you can make progress and deliver
your kids a head start relative to where
you were,
that's a win in the game.
So anyway,
again,
I don't want to trivialize any part of
this.
I think the unfairness of the way the
cards are dealt is really important and
we have obligations to address it.
But from the point of view of
individuals within the community trying
to plot a course,
beIng focused on the personal
responsibility side makes a ton of
sense.
What are you thoughts on affirmative
action?
I've changed my tune.
I used to be for affirmative action
because it is justified,
but now the um,
the downsides of it are they loom very
large for me.
And so what I would say is we want to
separate the,
whether or not it is justified to engage
in some kind of intentional intervention
to fix a problem that has become
chronic.
Um,
and then we separate that from what it
is that we are advocating and I don't
think the substitute for it is something
that anybody has properly spelled out.
But um,
but let's just say I would be much more
inclined to see a substantial investment
in community that makes sense rather
than it applied at the individual level.
Because I will say before any of what
happened to me at evergreen happen,
I did have the experience of having
quite a number of black students in
particular who suffered a totally a
stigma that had nothing to do with them.
Students who did very well on their own
merits,
who lived in a world that was quick to
judge them as having succeeded based on
some advantage that for all I know they
didn't even have.
I don't know that any of this.
I mean,
you know,
in the role of professor,
you don't necessarIly know how your
student ends up in front of you,
but I had no reason.
I had some very bright students who I
think suffered a stigma that came from
the fact that people in general imagined
that affirmative action was playing some
role in their world that it wasn't.
I mean,
affirmative action isn't even legal in
Washington.
So the fact that the stigma appends pens
to people is preposterous in that
context in particular.
That's fascinating.
Um,
I had a friend who was a fireman who
told similar stories and he was talking
about the resentment of the other people
that were on the fire force.
If a guy got in,
even if a guy was qualified,
if a guy was black because they assumed
that he wasn't as qualified,
and the reason why he got through it was
through affirmative action.
He was like,
it's so crazy because what it is is
they're trying to combat racism by
fueling racism advertently
yes.
It creates this whole cascade of
effects.
And so the question really the
civilization wide question is what do we
do about.
I mean,
we could retune the analysis for each of
the populations in questions.
In the case of black people in the new
world that is the americas,
most black folks in the new world are
here via the route of slavery.
And the thing is slavery was so brutal
in destroying the that these people had
access to where they came from and then
putting them together in a synthetic
culture that was built to serve the
masters.
Right?
In other words,
denying black folks the ability to learn
to read obviously limits access to the
huge library of insights that happened
to be a housed with the population that
transported these folks from,
from africa.
So in any case,
my point would be that is hobbling that
was intentionally hobbling during
slavery.
The legacy of that hobbling is one.
It's hard to quantify.
We don't know what role that plays,
but I can say any population that has,
I'm going to speak now as I do as a
biologist.
I think of us as robots that have a
computer on our shoulders that runs
software and our culture is the
software.
If you take that robot with the computer
and you delete the software package and
then you install some other software
package designed to make it do one
particular job that has tremendous harm
built into it and it's reversible,
but it is not.
I don't think we know that we didn't
succeed in fixing this problem.
I think the emancipation did not
properly deal with how much harm has
been done by bringing people from
different parts of africa and pooling
them in one population based on
effectively skin color alone.
And then at the point that they were
freed it,
there was no,
um,
there was no understanding because our
understanding of biology and culture
wasn't sophisticated yet.
It still isn't.
And so I think,
I think we do at some point have to do
an honest accounting of how much damage
happened in that process.
And we also have to realize that that
damage,
you know,
I mean,
I know right now having been active in
trying to make the world a better place,
I know that I'm running a foul of an
argument called white man's burden.
Right?
and so we all know that this is a
narrative,
but the point is that white man's burden
argument,
uh,
will be wielded against me for even
saying this,
but nonetheless,
I don't see any way around it.
I think the real story of what happened
in the americas is not,
um,
a nice story and the implications are
with us to this day,
nobody knows how deep they go because we
haven't studied the question properly.
And in fact many of the people who are
on the left pushing the sort of naive
narrative about equality are I think
fearful of what will happen if we study
the question.
I don't share their fear now.
I think you're right about fearful that
there's,
there's a lot of like what you were
talking about before,
like
with that woman bringing up ridiculous
things in meetings and people just sort
of showing their juggler,
please don't attack.
He got a lot of that.
I think of us in terms of,
you know,
the United States or just this massive
humans.
I think of us as a super organism and I
think if you had an organism that had a
broken knee,
he would go,
well,
I got to fix that knee.
You know,
I can't just give that need less work.
Is it possible to fix the knee?
Yeah.
Well let's fix the knee.
You don't want to just give the knee
last work,
you don't want to make it easier for the
knee to get by.
What you want to do is strengthen it.
So my thought,
and I've said this as a very simplistic
way of looking at it,
but if you really wanted to make America
great again,
right?
You really want to make America great.
What you would want to do is have less
losers,
so you'd want to go and find these
places where people are in these
economically deprived areas where
there's a ton of crime and violence and
they don't have like a real good sense
of like a potential positive outcome
from where they're at,
where they're at,
and transform that with a fraction of
the money that we spent trying to
rebuild nations and invading
Afghanistan.
We could invest in many of our gigantic
problems that we have in inner cities
and completely rebuild them.
It could be done and it could have
radical implications on the entire
country as a whole if you have,
instead of like a place like baltimore
for instance,
right.
I had Michael Woods on who was a former
police officer in baltimore and he sort
of explained all the different issues
that happen in baltimore,
particularly where there was areas where
they literally weren't selling homes to
black people.
They would not sell homes like this is a
like a white only area.
Like they had systematic racism built
into the system for a long time and just
if someone just invested money into the.
Not someone,
the United States government,
if we systematically invested money into
these places and rebuilt them with
community centers,
places where people could go where there
were safe staff,
them with a ton of people that were
motivated counselors.
The people that wanted to help give them
activities,
give them skills and trades and show
them ways out.
Give them a design it that's not nearly
as impossible as trying to rebuild
Afghanistan or nation building,
but we're doing that.
We're doing that all over the place.
I mean,
halliburton got no bid contracts for
billions of dollars to do shit that we
don't even know what the fuck they were
doing over there.
Right.
If we could have a fraction of that
money and invested into inner cities,
you could literally change entire
generations of human beings that are
coming out of there.
A couple things.
One,
by the way,
I love the analogy of the busted
knee because in fact we used to make
this mistake medically,
right until recently we didn't really
understand that part of the healing
process was not protecting the knee,
but putting it through physical therapy
that properly exposed it to stress this
so that it rebuilt and came back strong
and so we are making that error and we
have made that error in terms of what to
do with the stratification of society in
a way that locks up opportunity in some
communities and not others.
I think we should be honest with
ourselves about why that happens.
So I agree.
You could make what would be massive
investments in communities for a
fraction of what we spend tinkering
abroad in ways that have just spent huge
amounts of,
um,
of treasure on projects that didn't
work.
Right?
So we could do that.
The reason that that doesn't happen,
I don't think has anything to do with it
being an obvious that it would be a good
thing to do.
I think it has to do with the same group
selection issue that we were talking
about with respect to communism,
which is to say if you are at the top of
the system,
do you want to educate somebody else's
kids to compete with yours?
And so there's a reason that we.
Why do our public schools suck?
Is it because we don't know how to make
a school?
I don't think so.
I think it's because people know how to
make a school when it's for their kids
and they're not so interested in making
a school for other people's kids and so
this is a deep chronic problem with our
a sociopolitical system.
We have to confront that and actually I
think we have to.
We have to come to agreement that
actually it is in the long term wise to
educate other people's kids.
Even if in the short term it's
economically frightening.
Yeah.
The big conspiracy about children in
schools and keeping them stupid and
making sure that the school system is
frustrating.
And I mean,
that's uh,
I've always felt like that conspiracy
was really just,
there's no motivation to make it better.
I mean,
and,
and when you look at the amount of money
that teachers get paid him,
it says disturbing the,
you think of the,
uh,
the job of,
I don't have to tell you you're a god
damn teacher too deep,
but you got paid.
Don't go about it that way folks.
But the,
what you've,
what we're talking about here is the
most important thing that can happen to
your child in the developmental phase,
right?
The education.
Like giving them a view of the world,
explaining them all these things that
they had not known before.
Your first experiences with so many
different subjects and topics and
concepts come from your teachers.
And uh,
I got really lucky man.
I mean I went to a public school in high
school in newton,
Massachusetts.
I went to newton south high school and
it was a really good school and I still
had shitty teachers.
I still had,
you know,
even in that really good school,
it comparatively really good because I
went to a school before that in Jamaica
plain,
which was like an inner city school and
it was scary,
real dangerous,
just like just,
you know,
not like the most dangerous in boston,
but very sketchy.
Seventeen year old kids in seventh grade
that had never graduated like violence.
A lot of weirdness.
Like I had my head down for god through
that year and then all of a sudden I was
in this what we call fast times that
hebrew high because it was predominantly
jewish neighborhood,
but it was a.
Even then there was,
there was still some terrible teachers.
They're,
you know,
it's just the job is so important and we
in this country have done some weird
thing where we've taken one of the most
important jobs that you could ever.
You could ever hire someone to do
educate children and made it almost like
it's inconsequential.
Yeah.
And I'm hesitant.
I'm not always hesitant about
conspiracy.
There are conspiracies and we don't deal
well with it,
but one doesn't need conspiracy to
explain this.
This effectively can evolve without
anybody's consciously thinking I want to
sabotage somebody else's kids school.
Um,
but I will say my experience in school
was,
it was horrifying.
School did not work for me and maybe,
you know,
every five teachers I hit one invested
and cared and took the time to scratch
their head about why I wasn't
succeeding.
And uh,
that must have had an impact on you
though as an educator that you remember
those people.
Those one out of five.
Well,
this is the
funny thing is I,
while I was teaching,
I taught for 14 years at evergreen and I
felt like maybe I wasn't the only,
but I was very nearly the only person on
faculty anywhere that I could think of
who had not been a good student and
well,
but this was a very interesting window
because I became a professor because I
loved science.
And so the academy is where science
happened.
Not because I want it to be a teacher.
My experience in school made me want to
get away from the thing as fast as
possible.
But having had the experience of school
completely failing and my to my own
surprise,
learning how to think without school,
that's not where I learned that I
learned at primarily from my grandfather
and my brother and other people in my
environment who weren't associated with
school.
But once I got to being a professor,
and I think this was only possible at
evergreen,
evergreen made no rules about what you
did in the classroom.
Literally no rule about what subject you
taught.
They could hire you as a biologist and
could teach dance if people showed up to
take it.
So you could teach whatever you want in.
And the key was you could teach in
whatever way you wanted.
And so that's so crazy.
Well,
it's like a great idea if you're super
motivated,
it works two ways.
People abused it and they would use it
to reduce their workload to next to
nothing and they wouldn't invest in
their students.
And then other people looked at this and
they,
you know,
it was,
it was glorious to have that kind of
freedom.
And so I taught in a way that would have
worked for me if I had been a student
there,
which changed a lot of things and it
actually worked for a lot of bad
students,
don't typically become professors.
So there's almost nobody on the faculty
anywhere who has a clue why bad students
are the way they are,
right.
They just don't intuit it because it
wasn't their experience.
But if you were like me and you were a
bad student and then you ended up with a
class,
suddenly all sorts of bad students
aren't uncommon.
And so suddenly somebody who's speaking
to them and says,
I know that you're being a bad student
isn't synonymous with you not having
potential.
Right.
That's really empowering for them.
so anyway,
it was a,
it was an interesting experience and it
was.
My wife actually was a tremendous
student.
She loved school and we would actually
often teach the same students either
together or we would,
they would take my program and then they
would bounce over to her program next.
And so they would get these kind of two
different views.
And you know,
each of us,
we were both enlightened by our
relationship with each other because,
you know,
to the extent that I might've been
dismissive of the great students right
here,
I had one who,
you know,
was my,
my closest person on earth and you know,
I got to a window into how she saw the
world and she got a window into what the
kids who weren't performing well in
school might've been thinking.
And so anyway,
that was a very,
very useful background to have for
teaching.
There's a tremendous amount of power and
teachIng people.
It's a weird relationship between,
and especially when you're teaching
someone and you're giving them credit
towards their degree.
Um,
I,
I was very poor student in high school
and I've wasted a ton of time just going
to college.
So people didn't think I was a loser,
but I taught at boston university.
I used to teach taekwondo and I taught a
credited course.
It was pass fail a,
but it actually counted towards your
gpa.
So I hAd kids in my class and I would
tell them it's really simple,
just try and you get an a,
just show up and try and I'll give you
an a because like athletics or it's not,
it's not fair.
You know,
there's people that are just extreme end
dearborn person.
Their body holds onto too much fat and
they're not.
They didn't have a background in any
athletics.
They're not flexible.
It's very difficult for them to
understand how to move their body
correctly.
There's,
It's essentially like trying teach
someone
to be a professional speaker where
someone has been speaking english their
whole life where other people just
learning it for the first time.
It didn't seem fair to me.
So to judge them in terms of the actual
outcome.
That was like a.
It's almost contrary to what I said.
I was giving them a quality of outcome,
but not really.
No,
I,
I was.
I'm pretty sure I know what you were
doing because I did the same thing.
So I would tell students,
you show up and try and you are
completely safe.
You're going to get full credit and
you'll get a nice evaluation.
We wrote written evaluations to them,
but if you want an evaluation that raves
about you,
that talks about you know your,
your extraordinary capacity,
you're going to have to strive and so
what I wanted to do,
which sounds like what you were doing is
make them safe enough to discover what
they could do because I don't know
whether this will make sense to your
audience or not,
but I think we are overly concerned.
We have been sold.
The idea that the job of a teacher is to
assess how much the student has learned
that basically the job of the teacher is
largely to report out to the world how
qualified this person has.
That's a very hard job in some
disciplines in mind.
You know,
the student who did brilliantly,
I would know,
and the student who did nothing I would
usually know,
but there were lots of students in the
middle who might have gotten the lesson
really deeply and it might have matured
over the course of two years after they
were no longer in contact with me.
At the point I was writing the
evaluation of them that might not have
been a good place to assess how much
they've actually learned,
so I,
I steered away from the idea that my job
was to tell the world how well this
person had done,
unless they'd done great,
if they'd done really well,
if they'd,
you know,
surprise themselves and me about
everything that they were capable of.
I loved saying that,
but I didn't want to run down a student
who hadn't really shined in the
classroom because there's was a totally
artificial moment to judge how much they
had picked up.
Yeah.
No need to run them down.
Yup.
And again,
everybody's starting off at a different
position.
It's not like everybody's on the same
lIne and the gun goes off and everybody
runs with the first step in the same
spot.
It's just not the case.
right.
And there's some or many activities in
which your,
how you do initially doesn't necessarily
predict ultimately whether you'll be
unusually good.
Sure.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the things that I found,
particularly with athletics is that
people who are extraordinarily gifted
oftentimes don't excel because it seems
to come too easy for them and they never
develop the proper stamina for hard,
difficult work.
they shy away from that because if
things aren't easy,
they know.
Here's a perfect example.
People that are really gifted in one
asset,
one martial art,
like say like
someone who's gifted as a striker will,
they'll enter into mixed martial arts
and find that they really are not very
good at grappling.
And so they don't like that feeling of
being dominated in training.
So they don't give it 100 percent.
They don't throw themselves into it.
Instead,
they avoid it and they try to find
workarounds and they're almost always
defeated by grapplers.
It's like they,
they've,
because of the fact that they're gifted
and talented,
they've avoided the difficult real a
character building moments.
So this,
this is interesting that you say that.
I was on a train in New York and,
uh,
looking at twitter and somebody had
posted an article that caused the dime
to drop for me with respect to mixed
martial arts and why they were suddenly
a thing in my life where they hadn't
been.
I had assumed that it was simply the
fact that I'd showed up on your podcast
and obviously you're in that world.
and so a certain number of mixed martial
arts people,
we're now following me and I was seeing
their tweets and things.
But this guy,
I think his name is John Kirby,
posted an article that he had written
about Bruce Lee and his argument,
did you see this article?
No argument was why I'm Bruce Lee and
mixed martial arts points the direction
to how to fix our political dialogue
something.
Huh?
Um,
and so anyway,
his argument was,
and you know,
I'm no expert on this at all.
Um,
but his argument was that Bruce Lee,
effectively the,
the innovator at the beginning of mixed
martial arts,
was interested in testing a martial art
against all comers rather than requiring
the person on the other side to be
practicing the same martial art and that
there is a kind of model in that for
other disciplines than any,
anytime,
if your debate style requires somebody
to be debating in the same way on the
other side of the argument that it isn't
very strong,
right then it's a formalism.
But if you're reAlly good at arguing
that it shouldn't really matter as long
as the person speaks the same language,
you should be able to meet them on that
playing field and hash stuff out.
So anyway,
I,
I think a number of things linked up in
this way that there is a kind of
artificial boundary placed between
things and that,
those who are interested in tearing down
those boundaries,
even though that opens up a huge range
of things that they may face often have
something to teach in their particular
realm.
And um,
I was trying to think of other examples
of this and a lars anderson archer.
Again,
this is a place where you're an expert,
but what do you think of lars anderson?
Well,
he does like a lot of weird trick shots
with archery.
It's kind of fun to watch.
Very interesting stuff.
And what he's essentially done is he
believes he has not reinvented but
rediscovered a method of holding arrows
in your fingers so that you could,
with practice repeat here,
jamie's got video,
this character that you could release a
bunch of arrows in a row and he,
he's capable of shooting like way faster
than the average person and multiple
arrows.
He can throw things in the air and hit
it with multiple arrows before it hits
the ground.
Yep.
So my thought here is that this is,
I have a number of different examples.
So there is throwing them.
Oh,
here he's going to throw a bottle cap in
the air and he hits it with an arrow.
So crazy.
Even if there are lots of cuts here with
that,
we're not seeing where he misses the
fact that he can do this with enough
reliability to make a video to make a
video.
You can tell there are enough things
where he hits two things in one shot
that it's not,
it can't be completely fiction.
And if you look at his explanatory.
So he took a lot of crap for this from
people who were in the archery world who
didn't like the way he violated all of
the rules about what good archery form
looks like.
And so he made a response video.
English isn't his first langUage,
so it's a little hard to follow.
But,
um,
but any way it's pretty clear that what
he's done is he's just said,
well,
okay,
there are bose.
They're arrows.
What is the best way to think about
these things from the point of view of
solving these different problems?
And he's discovered a whole landscape of
stuff that I don't think you would
discover if you took archery and took it
seriously and learned from a master who
had good form.
You'd never discover it.
And,
uh,
I guess I'm there.
Might as well put the other examples on
the table.
Um,
let's see.
There's a danny macaskill,
the bicyclist.
Are you aware of this guy?
I feel like I've heard that name before.
Scottish kid.
He's very young.
Um,
I think at some point,
unfortunately he became a surprise
surprise sensation on youtube and red
bull figured out that he was a money
maker and they sort of pushed him.
So he's now had a couple of serious
accidents.
But,
um,
anyway,
he Is capable of doing things on a
bicycle especially,
you know,
in an urban environment,
hopping from
this guy,
this guy exists.
did you see that?
That was one of these guys,
these daredevil youtube,
god's just died.
a guy in China.
Oh god,
yeah.
this gets out of his,
out of his mind.
BuT I mean,
check that out for people that are
listening.
Only this guy's on a rooftop and he's
doing these stents where he's riding his
bike,
doing flips from one side of the
building to the other.
He's riding on the edges of the
building,
looking down,
hitting the brakes certain death on
either side.
I mean,
look at that.
Oh,
I have a hard time looking at that.
It's pretty rough.
But,
you know,
and it's fallen and hurt
himself.
and that's not a bmx bike either.
No,
it's like a regular bike.
It's,
it's,
uh,
I think it's not quite standard,
but it's a,
it's more mountain bike proportions,
but anyway,
just,
it's probably has to b to b.
So rugged,
right?
Oh yeah.
It's souped up in particular ways so
that it can endure the kind of forces
that he's on it.
But he's,
he's discovered stuff about what you can
do with a bicycle that I think you just.
I mean,
in fact,
you know,
in the era we grew up,
we didn't know that these things were
possible and you know,
what he's doing emerged from,
uh,
from observed trials,
which was a very regimented kind of
competition for,
for mountain bikers.
But,
um,
but anyway,
he's discovered a landscape of
possibilities on a bicycle,
not unlike the lamps landscape of
possibilities that lars anderson has
discovered in a,
in archery park who are,
is another place where,
you know,
growing up,
I didn't know that all that was possible
and I thought,
um,
you know,
frankly,
I thought that olympic gymnastics was
pretty interesting.
And you know,
now I look at olympic gymnastics and I
think that's a.
I mean,
I get it.
It's team.
And the thing is it has one advantage
which is that everything is so
standardized that you can compare to
competitors.
If you want to award a medal,
it maybe it has to look like olympic
gymnastics,
but,
um,
but these guys who can look at an urban
environment and figure out how they can
make use of these objects and their
relationship to each other,
uh,
are discovering something about what the
human body is capable of.
That isn't the obvioUs.
Uh,
if you,
you know,
if there isn't somebody to pointed out,
so there are innovators.
I don't even know if we know who the
initial innovators are with something
like park who are probably somebody
does.
Russians could be russian kids.
You ever seen those videos of them
hanging off of the side of buildings?
I really think that they were the
innovators of this,
the,
that was the first stuff that we ever
saw.
Maybe french word,
right?
What's our core french?
I think so,
yeah.
Um,
but in any case,
uh,
one of the things,
and you know,
you,
when you,
uh,
when you asked me to come on,
we,
we decided we would talk a little bit
about what to do about planet earth
because I had mentioned the first time
was on your show that,
that was a,
uh,
an employee from parker.
Well,
but my feeling is actually this is,
this is about parker and my point is
where we are with civilization.
We're stuck and we are on a trajectory
that you don't have to be deeply
knowledgeable to recognize that it is
unstable on enough different fronts that
we can't go on like this much longer.
We're playing with powerful enough tools
that were in tremendous danger.
Something going wrong,
and so the question is,
it's very hard to imagine how you use
normal tools,
you know,
are you going to win an election and get
policy through congress that's going to
change the world and suddenly make us,
it's almost impossible to imagine
something like that happening.
And so the question is,
is there a park core kind of innovation,
something that is not obvious to us,
that's,
it's there.
The city was always there.
People were not always doing park who
are with the objects in it,
but they could have been.
And so are we missing the obvious?
Is it in front of us,
what we're supposed to do to take a
civilization that's hurdling out of
control with too many people consuming
too fast,
um,
and using mechanisms that are dangerous.
Is there a route to put us back on track
to something reasonable that looks like
one of these innovations that you don't
know it existed until somebody shows you
that it's there?
So what do you think those things are?
Well,
I assume there's more than one,
right?
There's more than one.
I would say the conversation doesn't
sound familiar and I don't think anybody
has the answer to that question.
I,
before I go deeply into this question,
I should probably say something a little
bit self protective,
which is talking about the question of
what to do with planet earth can be.
It can be an idol of discussion,
in which case there's no,
there's nothing to be navigated,
but if you want to do it seriously,
there's a danger of triggering a kind
of,
um,
reflective penalty that we all carry
around.
So arrogance is something that we don't
like.
people don't like to hear people being
arrogant and so we all have like a
detector for that,
that we,
we,
we listen.
And when somebody strays into arrogance,
maybe it goes off in order to have a
conversation about what to do about
planet earth.
Obviously we're talking about very
serious stuff and for anybody to
contemplate that they might know or
might be tuned into a conversation that
could find its way to some new answer.
We are in danger of triggering that.
uh,
oh my god,
that's arrogant circuit.
And so at some level,
in order to have this conversation
properly,
I need to,
I need to turn off my own sensitivity to
hearing that little warning bell in my
own head.
And you know,
if,
if the conversation is preposterous,
a fine,
that's something a reasonable person
could conclude about.
Anybody who was talking about changing
the way the world functions.
maybe it is preposterous and I leave
that possibility open.
And the other hand,
um,
you know,
I have kids,
I'm pretty sure I can do the math myself
on how much danger we're in.
I may not know the full extent of it,
but I can tell that we're in enough
danger that we have to do something
counter intuitive and different enough
that it stands a chance of changing the
way the place functions or my kids.
and your kids are in serious trouble.
So anyway,
that's why I would,
would go down this road,
but I have to do it in that kind of
context where I'm not too worried about
whether people hear this as,
you know,
me being full of myself or something
like that.
Does that makes sense?
Why would,
why would I get it?
It's a lack.
Those self protective instincts.
I just spout off.
All right,
fair enough.
But go ahead.
Okay.
so there are a lot of.
So I should say where,
where does this all come from?
My initial foray into this style of
thinking actually starts with erIc,
who you had on your podcast.
I saw a lot of feedback about him on
your podcast was great.
People were really jazzed about.
Brilliant.
You have brilliant brother.
I have all noticed that he is absolutely
amazing and there's no place to hide
from him because he is so good across,
you know,
all levels of analysis.
So he obviously even on your podcast,
he was playing around in biology space.
Very adeptly.
I can't do that.
I can't go over into math space and do
the same favor for him.
But um,
but anyway,
yeah,
he's a,
he's a very interesting thinker and
across many more levels than I think
anybody else I've encountered.
But anyway,
he,
some years ago,
after the financial collapse of 2008,
he decIded that there needed to be a
proactive discussion about what had gone
wrong and economic space that had
allowed that catastrophe to happen.
And so he and some collaborators put
together a conference called the
economic manhattan project.
It was at the perimeter institute in,
in Canada.
And so I went,
I attended this conference and it was,
it was the first place I encountered an
intentional conversation about changing
a large enough piece of the puzzle to
actually fix the way the world works to
prevent another financial collapse like
the one that happened in 2008.
And I also met people at that conference
who have continued on in these
conversations.
Um,
I joined occupy,
I mean,
not that there was anything really to
join,
but I participated in it in hopes that
it would turn into something capable of
changIng the way we functioned.
And I ended up being very disappointed
and frustrated by the quality of the
conversation inside of,
of occupy wall street.
But anyway,
it,
it revealed some things to me.
And then after that,
there was a,
um,
a group of people who gathered in a
something that ultimately was called
game be end.
Game b is really where the thinking that
I want to talk to you about emerged most
clearly.
Game be no longer exists,
but a group of us from across the
political spectrum,
various different kinds of expertise.
we had tech people,
we had professors from various different
disciplines.
We had a buddhist,
I mean we really had a lot of different
people who were united basically by an
understanding that,
that they had each arrived at the
trajectory we were on was so dangerous
that it required us to take action.
And we tried out various different ideas
about what might,
what might be sufficient to,
um,
to avert the danger we were heading
towards and give humanity more time to,
to find a way to exist on the planet.
So I should probably say something about
what game b means and it carries a
relevance into,
into what we might do in the present.
Game b was basically proceeded from the
idea that what we live in is a game
theoretic landscape,
right?
That the winners in this game theoretic
landscape are individuals who have
figured out where there's a niche,
some of them have figured out how to
engage in something called rent seeking,
which rent seeking basically means
making money without producing some
without producing value.
So there's a lot of stuff that goes on
in our economy that is not productive
and good,
but nonetheless generates fortunes.
So that's rent seeking as opposed to
innovation or productivity.
You're talking about like hedge fund
type stuff,
moving money around.
Well,
I want to be a little careful about this
because it is quite possible for things
like hedge funds to actually correct
inefficiencies in the economy in a way
that is productive.
It doesn't mean that that's the average
thing.
That's two things.
Are you referring to?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
let's,
let's take the,
the ultimate example that will make it
clear.
A warlord is not responsible for,
um,
for building the road that they then
stand by the side of and extort money
from people who want to travel it.
A cable company may produce some
benefit.
They obviously have infrastructure that
allows you to get content,
but what fraction of what you're paying
for is actually about them delivering a
service at some price and making some
reasonable profit.
And what fraction of it is about the
fact that they are an economic goliath
and that you don't have enough choice to
be able to negotiate a decent price with
them.
So there's some fraction of what they're
producing that is productive,
but then there's a large amount of
profit there that isn't about
productivity or innovation.
It's about the fact that they own a
choke point and you can't get around it.
Um,
so we don't know what fraction of the
economy is a rent seeking and what
fraction of it is productive.
But there is,
especially if one is broadminded about
thinking about all the ways that one can
engage in rent seeking.
One can actually be destructive of value
if you destroy future wellbeing for our
descendants,
It may look productive in the present,
but it isn't productive.
It's actually destructive.
So that's a kind of rent seeking that we
don't even typically model.
But uh,
where,
where are we headed?
So,
oh yes.
So we live in a game theoretic landscape
that's both good and bad.
As you point out,
competition is a healthy thing and
competition in markets produces a huge
amount of value.
So I hear people,
deriding capitalism,
and I always want to make the same point
to them,
which is you've got two things glued
together and you are challenging them as
a package,
but there's no reason they have to be
packaged.
So we would be foolish to give up
markets.
Markets are amazingly powerful.
Engines of innovation.
they are capable of solving problems
that we cannot solve deliberately,
even if we want it to.
so we need markets,
but we don't want markets ruling the
planet and deciding that anything that
spits out a profit is therefore good and
that we should be exposed to whatever
the market discovers can be a viable.
So what we want is ultimately to
provide,
um,
provide incentive structures that caused
the market to produce things that are
good for us,
right?
In other words,
have you tell the market that you want
the solution to some problem,
the market can figure out how to solve
that problem and it will do it very
well.
But if you allow the market to decide
what problems to solve,
it may end up,
for example,
addicting you to your phone,
right addicting to you,
to your phone in a way that harms your
social relationships,
harms your,
your parenting of your children,
harms all kinds of things that are
really important,
breaks the ability of your children to
have a educational experience in school.
we don't want the market discovering how
to disrupt useful functioning of people.
We want the market to stay out of that
stuff.
And then to provide us benefits that,
uh,
only,
can provide like all of the mechanisms
that now allow us to navigate seamlessly
in places that we've never been avoiding
traffic that we wouldn't know to worry
about,
right?
Those are huge benefits and they're
capable of taking a city that is to
snarled with traffic and reducing the
degree to which it is snarled with
traffic.
So they're very powerful,
but we shouldn't,
we shouldn't throw the baby out with the
bathwater.
markets are good.
Allowing markets to discover any and
every mechanism for exploiting you is
not good at all.
And in fact,
it's a large part of why we're in the
predicament that we're in,
is that we let the market decide what
problems to solve and then if it solves
them and they're very,
a lucrative,
there's no way to say no.
Once I say attractive to people.
I mean,
that's one of the reasons why a phone,
uh,
so addictive is because it's attractive
because you can get access to
information at the drop of a hat.
So you just constantly one of feed that
machine it constantly to like,
oh,
well,
what can I do?
Can I play a game on it?
Ooh,
can I take a picture of myself?
can I give myself a dog knows?
Oh,
right.
But imagine.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing to me that it's even hard
to do this thought experiment,
but put yourself in,
you know,
in your own mind 15 years ago and
present yourself the deal that the phone
represents,
you know,
hey joe,
alright,
check this phone out,
right?
This phone is going to allow you to
navigate in a place you've never been.
It's going to connect you with all sorts
of people who share your interest.
You're going to be able to say a
sentence that you think is clever and
suddenly hundreds or thousands of people
are going to be able to react to it.
I mean all sorts of marvelous.
Thanks.
And then the point is,
well,
here's the downside,
okay,
you're going to be hooked into mega
corporations that are going to study
your psychology and they are going to
compete in order to keep you paying
attention to their site and they're
going to become so sophisticated that
you're going to lose control over your
own mind.
You are going to become addicted to it
in the way that you might become
addicted to nicotine.
Right?
so that that's a pretty high cost.
What's more,
you are going to surveil yourself,
you're going to surveil yourself and
your only protection from surveilling
yourself are going to be end user
license agreements that you're not going
to be legally sophisticated enough to
understand and so you're going to be at
the mercy of whoever has access to your
phone camera,
your metadata,
your,
you know,
all of these things.
So the point is,
if you sAid this to you 15 years ago,
you'd know to be afraid of it,
right?
I probably wouldn't be like,
eh,
I'll put it down if I don't like it.
Okay,
well,
I must tell you,
if you told me that I was going to be
bugging myself with a sophisticated
device like that,
that I know I can't even.
I can't even turn it upside down because
of the camera on both sides of the dams.
I mean the cost is really high,
but we signed up for it incrementally in
a way that never left the ability to say
no and what's worse,
it is not inconceivable.
If we discovered that the net cost of
such a device exceeded the value of it
by 10 times,
we still couldn't get rid of them.
You can't pull them back.
You can't unmake them.
There's too much benefit to them though.
You're,
you're,
you're making it seem as if it's only a
negative,
but it's not only a negative,
it's also answering every single
question you could ever have about
anything technical,
anything involving history,
anything involving facts and obviously
in today's day and age with hashtag fake
news,
you're going to get a lot of bullshit
facts in there as,
but just
the sheer access to information,
they'd be able to ability to contact
each other instantaneously as a lot of
pros to it.
Huge number.
I'm believe me,
I'm not underwriting the value of.
I mean you just,
you know,
you pointed to it yourself.
Having even just wikipedia in your
pocket is like,
that's such a fantastic gift to have
that access to information not only on
your home computer but right there in
your pocket.
That's amazing.
So I'm not saying the benefit isn't
spectacular and you know,
I've signed up for it like everybody
else,
but the cost is very high end.
Didn't have to be.
In other words,
if you had set the bounds in which the
market was going to solve this problem
so that you,
for example,
prevented it from breaching our ability
to protect our own privacy.
You could have had the benefit of
wikipedia and instant communication and
all of these things without the huge
downside.
So the privacy issue being cookies or
cameras like which.
Which one are you referring to?
Well,
first of all,
I think the cameras are a bit of a red
herring.
I don't think anybody at.
First of all there's a huge amount of
data involved in video to the extent
there's an issue.
It would be more about the microphone
and the fact that it can listen in to
conversations and basically track who's
thinking what.
And there's so much power in that
potentially,
that even,
even if it's not being used presently,
it's only a matter of time before
somebody taps into that data and starts
using it to shape things they are not
entitled to shape.
Um,
so how do we fix it?
Well,
so I mean,
we've gotten a little off track here.
Game a is what we live,
right?
It's a market in which we decide how to
behave.
And if we have insight,
maybe we come out ahead.
If we don't have correct insight,
maybe we lose.
But anyway,
that's,
that's gay may.
It's,
it's,
it's the market as we find it.
Game b was the idea that,
um,
that there are ways that you could
restructure the deal we have with each
other so that you could compete in game
a's terms without losing to game.
So the,
the conclusion.
And again,
game b is not a live organization
anymore,
but it was a place in which a lot of
work was done that I think feeds into
the conversation about what we do very
clearly in order to change the way the
world functions.
Most of the mechanisms that have
fUnctioned in the past are no longer
viable,
is almost inconceivable to imagine that
you could have a revolution in any
standard sense that would successfully
capture power and then wielded wisely.
I can't even imagine it happening.
So game b is the idea that one needs to
create an entity that is capable of
competing in the market.
It is capable of competing in game a,
his terms and winning against game a,
so game a is the way things run.
Game b is an alternative that can
compete in today's terms and when,
and that sounds first time you hear it,
it sounds preposterous because the
system has so much inertia in it that
you would think it is completely
impervious to any challenge,
but there's a hidden factor which I
think is evident in those various
examples we were looking at in parker
and lars anderson and his archery
innovations and danny macaskill.
I would also say jane goodall and her
success at sorting out what was going on
with chimps.
The point is systems that become very
difficult to dislodge,
that have great inertia are almost
inevitably feeble.
In a particular fashion,
so this is true of academic disciplines,
to if a discipline becomes stuck,
it is very hard to get a hearing within
the discipline,
but the discipline loses track of where
it has made assumptions that aren't true
or aren't certain and so it becomes
relatively easy to compete against it.
Uh,
if you're not requiring it to validate
your perspective.
So that feebleness is a feature of our
system.
Our system is delivering the,
the goods to people at a low rate.
Most people are dissatisfied,
they're unhealthy,
they are not well protected from things
like bad luck.
ANd those are all problems that can be
solved by a,
an entity that is capable of
restructuring the deals between peOple.
In other words,
let's take an obvious one.
Like insurance insurance is not well
delivered by a market and there's a very
good reason it isn't,
which is that the strategy for winning
in the delivery of insurance is
perfectly obvious.
You want to insure people who need it
very little and you want to uninsured
people who needed a lot.
That's how you win the insurance game.
So the insurance industry is always
looking to make that deal with the world
and that's always looking to figure out
how to,
uh,
to,
to disengage or those who are most
likely to need it.
And what that means is that we can't
provide a risk pool.
The risk pool just means you don't know
if you're going to get a brain tumor.
I'm going to get a brain tumor.
So how about we both agree to pay for
whoever's treatment needs it and whoever
has the bad luck wins in that deal and
whoever has the good luck loses,
but because we don't know who it is
ahead of time,
it's a win for both of us,
right?
So that structure is one that you can
build inside of this competitive
architecture.
And uh,
what I'm,
what I'm getting at is that the
conversation of people that has
coalesced,
people who are discussing the question
of how to make things function in a way
that solves the problems that we all
face,
um,
without having to win some unimaginable
electoral victory or to challenge these
governments outright.
That conversation centers around a game
theoretic,
um,
insight.
And this is something I mentioned before
that I had participated in occupy and
had been quite disappointed and really
where I was before I ran into this
conversation was I was,
if I'm honest with myself,
I was becoming a little desperate
because I could see how much trouble we
were in,
but every mechanism that you might use
to fix it seemed very unlikely to
function.
When I heard a presentation that said,
actually there's a mechanism that does
not go through any of the familiar
historical means,
but uses tools that we all see deployed,
right?
The same tools that caused a facebook to
be successful can be used to repair the
system.
That begins to sound plausible to me
that make any sense
sort of.
But this is,
we're,
we're on a long road.
Yeah.
Is there a way to boil this down?
Well,
let's try an example.
How do you feel about bitcoin?
A?
I think,
I think it's fascinating.
You wish you had more of it?
Well,
no,
I have some of it,
but it's not mine.
It's all donated towards a fight for the
forgotten.
They're building wells in the Congo.
Uh,
I had andreas antonopoulos on and he
introduced me to bitcoin,
so he set up a bitcoin wallet for me.
I took donations from people,
but I didn't think it was right.
They just gave me,
it was very little at the time,
but I said I'll just give this to my
friend justin who builds wells in the
Congo.
So now it's worth with it with like 70
grand or something like that,
something like that.
But he's got to figure out when he wants
to cash out.
It's up to him.
But uh,
so far they've gotten at least 10,000
out of it and we've built a bunch of
wells with that money.
So I think it's great in that regard.
It's served an amazing purpose for those
people in the Congo.
Well,
the people were actually mad at me that
I didn't buy those things with bitcoin
that instead used the,
the acap,
the bitcoin,
but gave him the money value of the
bitcoin.
They were upset,
like,
why didn't you just pay for it with
bitcoin?
But about,
I wanted to see as an experiment where
the bitcoin goes and turns out it was a
lucky guess on my part and now it's
worth far more because what was worth
5,000
at the time is now
a hundred grand.
Right?
So we don't all like it.
Okay.
I like that too.
And whether it's bitcoin or not,
there's something clearly happening in
the,
uh,
in the blockchain cryptocurrency.
Yes.
So people,
the world is trying to figure out which,
which of these currencies is going to
function at the moment.
It's blockchain is looking the most
promising.
There are obstacles to add functioning.
There are ways in which those obstacles
are being addressed and you know,
It'd be pointless to get into the
details of it community.
I really,
I really liked the idea behind it.
To me,
I like things that don't have a whole
lot of rules where people sort of figure
out what's right.
Right.
Good.
So if we take 'em bitcoin as an example
of something that addresses the problems
of fiat currency,
lIke the dollar,
nobody asked permission to build it.
In fact,
we don't even know who innovated it.
It's a pseudonym that we have.
We don't know whose identity it is.
recently someone thought it was elon
musk,
which I would not be surprised.
that crazy guy,
uh,
you know,
I couldn't say,
and I think it,
it doesn't much matter what we know is
that somebody without asking permission,
found a better model for a currency that
addressed issues that we all face and
we're not individually capable of
addressing ourselves.
And it's pretty clear that a,
something in this realm is going to win
and it's going to become an important
player,
if not the important player on the world
stage currency wise.
that is a,
an entity which exists in game a space,
right?
You can convert bitcoin to dollars.
That's not hard.
Bitcoin functions inside of this realm.
It's not illegal.
It works.
It's reliable.
The problems had been solved by people
because solving those problems made
sense that it enriched them for doing
so.
They made their currency more
functional.
So that entity is a solution that is
superior to game a,
but it functions in gamer terms.
It's winning in gay terms at the moment.
Now I'm not saying it isn't going to
crash.
It probably is going to crash because
it's probably overinflated at the
moment.
How much will the crash?
Will it come back?
Are we going to go through repeated
bubbles and bitcoin will still went out.
I don't nobody clearly nobody knows,
but the idea that it is a superior
solution invented inside this other
system that is winning against the
dollar at the moment.
That's a fine example.
Likewise,
you could use wikipedia as a fine
example.
This is an entity that is functioning
inside.
It is competing with the old
encyclopedias that is competing with for
profit services that would deliver
information and uh,
frankly it's winning because it's
superior.
It was a perfect no,
but,
um,
but it's a,
it's a demonstration that you can do
things inside this space that in fact
have reorganized our relationship to
information.
And in fact,
uh,
in a way that we don't typically
acknowledge is challenging the,
the academy.
I mean,
maybe part of why the academy was so
feeble at the point that this social
justice madness started to challenge it
had to do with the fact that without the
academy's permission,
information became free.
The fact that everybody,
there was a level playing field for
information meant that the academy
needed to figure out what it was going
to deliver on top of that information
and it didn't figure it out and I would
say there was an obvious answer which it
missed.
It needed to deliver stuff that didn't
scale.
It needed to teach,
um,
insight and critical thinking and how to
wield that information properly rather
than continuing to deliver textbook
level information when effectively
textbooks are obsolete.
Um,
but these are,
these are examples of successful
competitivelY successful,
innovative challenges to the model that
preexisted them.
And the question is,
can that set of models be systematized
so that it,
um,
without having to do the impossible,
simply replaces the system as it stands
because it delivers the things to the
system claims to deliver more
successfully than the system delivers.
Okay.
Like what things are we talking about?
We're talking about insulation from bad
luck.
Luck is a tremendously negative
influence,
so like insurance,
but ensuring that we collectively
utilize correct something that we
collectively utilized.
So imagine that you could have wonderful
insurance,
but that in signing up for that
you were agreeing to some sort of a
larger social entity,
so like your taxes would go towards a
life insurance,
but meaning like things that go wrong in
life,
like some part of what you would spend
on things would be attributed to this
fund.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
uh,
it's,
I think we unfortunately default to
thinking of everything in monetary
terms.
You could also invest in such an entity.
Let you know.
Let's talk about the question of
teachers that you were pointing out.
Why are good teachers so few and far
between?
Well,
of course we pay at a level that we get
exactly what we ordered and you know,
the few good teachers that we run into
are by and large people who are doing it
in spite of the fact that they're being
economically penalized for doing it.
But what if your,
um,
your insurance,
your access to excellent insurance that
correctly hedged out the danger of bad
medical,
bad luck came with some sort of social
obligation in which,
you know,
I don't know,
the three years after you had gone to
graduate school and gotten your advanced
degree in something you spent teaching
in some school that needed that so you
didn't sideline yourself from the
economy for the rest of your life
teaching in some school where you were
forever going to be hobbled by bad
administrators,
but you decided to take some period of
time and invested in,
uh,
your community or somebody else's
community using expertise that,
um,
that you got that you'll be highly paid
for later.
So it's almost like you have mandatory
military service manager.
It mandatory military service is,
yes,
it is one version of a much larger space
of potential agreements that you could
sign up for an exchange for benefits
that you can't.
Most of us cannot negotiate on the open
market.
So,
uh,
to get your education,
you would agree to use that education
for the good of the community for a
certain amount of time.
Absolutely.
So instead of walking away with massive
debt that is going to hobble you in
economic terms as you're trying to,
to find your niche that you would sign
up for some agreement that was,
you know,
but wouldn't that still benefit the
elite?
Because what of scrooge mcduck has a kid
and scrooge mcduck kid,
uh,
he pays for his kids education.
I listened,
son,
you're not going to do any service which
are going to do is use those three years
to get ahead.
And those little fox,
when they get out of that service,
I've got to be working for you.
Ha.
They throw the gold coins up in the air.
Right?
So this is another place,
a nice look.
This is another place where two things
are fused together that we need to tease
apart.
Okay?
I'm trying to remember.
I think Eric May have actually said this
on your podcast.
I'm,
if he didn't,
he said it elsewhere,
but elites is not a good category,
right?
Elites takes two things that don't
belong together and it decides that they
are one.
And so the scrooge mcduck thing becomes
it blocks the other thing we want people
to innovate.
And one of the reasons that equality of
outcome is absolutely not desirable,
even if you could arrange it,
is that the inequality of outcome is the
incentive that drives people to achieve
amazing stuff that we want them to
achieve.
Right?
Of course.
So how far ahead of everybody else
should you end up?
Well,
this is a difficult problem because you
to the extent that somebody earns a
fortune because they've,
um,
they have innovated in a,
in an important way,
but then they have gone on to be a rent
seeker.
We don't want them re rewarded for their
rent seeking,
but we do want them rewarded for their
innovation.
Um,
so there,
the problem is the elite is two
different things and even worse
individuals are members of the elite are
composites of both things where you get
into the elite because you innovated
something amazing.
But the degree to which you had been
rewarded is,
I dunno,
60,
70 percent,
the result of rent seeking rather than
what you innovate.
It meant,
again,
for people who are just tuning into us
now rent seeking meaning,
doing things to which you extract money
from the system without any real benefit
to the people that are around you.
Yeah.
It's anytime that you get paid without
producing something of value,
either innovation or productivity itself
or something like that.
But how would you regulate that?
How would you,
how would you figure out a way to
regulate the amount of profit that
someone could like if you have a system,
right?
And if you build something and then you
get,
you know,
some sort of a residual benefit from
that system because you built it and so
you're not really doing anything but
you're just constantly collecting money
from this thing.
How would you stop that or regulate
that?
Well,
as aN example of it,
what I just,
the way I just described it,
yeah,
it's,
it's a pretty good example.
um,
you know,
we do want.
So it's a very tough conversation
because one has to be very careful that
you don't remove an incentive to do
something valuable,
even though the value of it may be very
subtle.
So the example of investment like
playing the stock market might look on
productive,
but to the extent that you are
correcting the fact that certain things
are undervalued and other things are
overvalued,
you're actually doing a kind of service
that is not as obvious on the outsIde
unless you've spent time thinking about
the logic of why you want the market to
be efficient.
Um,
so I don't want to,
I don't want to,
uh,
declare that certain things are In and
of themselves bad because we can't see
the obvious value of them.
On the other hand,
there's an awful lot of stuff that is
either totally valueless for which
people are very handsomely paid or
worse.
Um,
counterproductive.
Destructive of value,
right?
If,
if you take waste and you get paid to
dispose of it and you dispose of it in a
way that it creates cancers where you
can't detect that they have been created
by what you've done.
But it's not that you solved the problem
of that waste,
you just caused cancers in random homes
that won't be able to trace their,
their misfortune to your action.
That's not,
not only is that unproductive,
but it's counterproductive.
It's harmful.
So how do you address these questions?
Well,
a you.
this is a much harder problem if you
imagine that what you want to do is fix
the landscape that you're walking into
and say you're a rent seeker and you're
productive and you're 30 percent
productive,
but 70 percent of rent secret,
nobody believes you can do that.
What you can do is restructure things so
that going forward,
what is rewarded is actual productivity
that is not harmful or actual innovation
that is not harmful
and what is panelized and what you
really want.
if you,
if the system is to function,
what you want is a disincentIve to do
anything that hurts other people that
has a net negative impact on the system.
The bp oil spill,
bp oil spill,
the aliso canyon,
a leak the mile island,
three mile island fukushima 10th degree.
So how do you.
I'm still confused as to what's
different,
like what's going on here?
Um,
what is going on is that if you,
if you array incentives so that at the
point you have solved a problem that is
good to solve,
that the wellbeing starts flowing in
your direction.
You made it perfect widget.
Everybody goes,
oh my god,
this fixes my life.
Right?
I love this widget.
So by a bunch of them,
you start,
you start bawling,
get Paul Wall grill.
Exactly.
But as you start moving in the direction
of doing something that interferes with
other people's wellbeing,
but nonetheless they can't help
themselves.
If you're innovating how to addict
people to their phone,
then actually you're hurting people and
we don't want you to do that.
Now it's very hard again,
are you going to tell facebook?
You know what it's allowed to study and
also people that have good intentions,
but it turns out that they're like,
facebook is a perfect example.
One of the executives from facebook,
I was just reading on dig the other day.
There was an article,
uh,
where he was sorry for what they've
done.
It was one of the original guys from
facebook.
it's like,
I really think that we've done a
terrible thing with facebook and we've
made people addicted to social media.
Facebook is seems to me to be
particularly addictive and I'm not
exactly sure what they've done different
than anybody else,
but so much so that I kind of avoid
facebook,
you know,
it's funny how many conversations I've
had in the last month in which somebody
has said that they're avoiding facebook
and including me.
I like instagram because I just see
pictures and they look pretty and
simple.
well,
yeah,
I mean,
each of these things has their,
uh,
their value.
I'm not on instagram.
I'm on twitter.
I'm on twitter too.
full.
For me,
what's good about it is this,
it,
you're being programmed former facebook
executive.
Warren's for me,
for my business,
it's very important to let people,
hey,
bret weinstein is going to be on today.
As I said it right earlier,
People tune in and you know,
now there's people that are listening
right now because of social media.
Right?
And then,
you know,
comedy shows that I have coming out,
but it works for me and a lot of those
ways.
But as time has gone on,
I've pushed it away and most otherwIse.
Well,
and the thing,
the,
the interview that you just referenced,
I saw it too and was quite blown away by
it.
Um,
I've been tuned into that because
tristan harris is a friend
of mine and tristan harris is sort of
the,
uh,
the paul revere on this issue who has
pointed out how much danger we are
actually in and I must say he's a very
interesting guy because his,
his other area of expertise is magic.
And so he's very interested in.
Yeah,
exactly.
Interesting.
And so anyway,
he's,
he's watched as an insider,
as these,
uh,
economic goliath have conspired to not
let us go and to turn their product from
a facilitator of social interaction into
a cigarette,
which is,
you know,
or a slot machine or something like
that.
Um,
but,
uh,
the,
how would you penalize them then say if
there's this new system,
how would that work?
Say if you came up with this new widget
and this new widget does amazing things,
but turns out it also makes you addicted
to widgets.
Okay,
so I'm speaking only for myself here.
I would not penalize facebook or
twitter,
but what I would want to see is somebody
generate the alternative that has the
benefit of not doing that.
Okay,
so a new facebook that doesn't work with
likes and all these things are.
You're not constantly checking in the
likes,
but it wouldn't be.
Here's the thing.
It wouldn't be a successful people love
likes.
That's why girls stick their butt out
and those pictures,
they want to get those likes.
That's what that's all about it is that
they've said first of all,
that people that do that,
you know what those things are called,
which things.
When girls stick their butt out and they
have traps,
thirst traps,
yeah,
you don't know about that.
I don't know about thirst traps.
I'm going to tell you,
thirst traps are you look for people
that are thirsty.
They were like,
ooh girl,
you look good.
Damn.
You look good.
People who are like extra thirsty,
thirsty means you never get thirsty.
Okay.
You're married,
you've been around intellectuals and
trapped up in progressive pacific
northwest.
You're not going to embarrass their
friend.
No,
don't worry.
Is thirsty is people who are trying too
hard,
like like you're not the type person.
If you saw someone who is a beautiful
girl who was in a bikini,
you would say,
wow,
that is a beautiful girl in a bikini and
what an incredible body she has and you
would move on.
You wouldn't be like,
damn girl,
you look so fun.
How can I get what you did?
You would be super thirsty,
right?
That would be thursday.
So I'm trying too hard.
But the internet is filled with thirsty
people and so a lot of these girls
become famous.
There's girls that you've never heard of
them.
Okay.
I had a bit about it and yeah,
my last special about there was a girl
that I,
she,
all she does is take pictures of her,
but and at the time she had 7 million
followers now,
but she's got 100 million or something.
I don't know,
but that these people become
these,
these places where everybody goes to
stare at their butt and these pictures
of them and their bodies and all these
different things are traps for all these
weird people that lack normal social
skills and their uber thirsty.
A thirst trap.
Okay,
well this.
That's the whole reason why these people
use things like instagram and she that
thirst trap had a thirst trap on
instagram with cardi,
b,
c,
I'm ty.
I'm talking about the kids today.
This girl,
I'm beginning to think maybe we can't
save the world,
but listen,
we can save the world,
but the problem is we have to be
cognizant of normal human desires and
like the the traps thirst traps.
Okay,
so this is actually the perfect place to
go then because one of the biggest
obstacles to fixing the world is that
although a huge fraction of the
population is actually aware that things
are off and they would like it to be
better,
there's so much low level stuff that
keeps us trapped in these unproductive
kinds of cycles and one of the things
that I keep running into now,
I'm now being included in all of these
conversations with folks who do aspire
to something better,
but everybody,
and I mean really just about everybody
has stuff that to them is sacred and
they want to take it off the table.
Right?
They,
they,
they're very interested in the
conversation about how we might fix the
world,
but you know,
if they're a libertarian,
the point is as soon as you.
You can't even finish the word regulate
and they're just like,
oh,
well,
sorry.
Who?
Who watches the watchers?
And the point that it's a bitter pill
for just about everybody who's got some
sacred thing that they're holding onto
is you are.
If we deploy something that functions
well and is capable of replacing the
system,
we have without some gigantic
catastrophe necessary in order to get
over the transition.
The whole point is to everyone's net
benefit,
right?
If liberty is your thing and I'm
virtually sure liberty is your thing,
as it is my thing,
that you will get more liberty net
liberty will go up in a system that
functions well.
Many of the things that caused us not to
be free have nothing to do with
governmental regulation.
They have to do with expectations that
have been created by a market that does
not have our interests at heart,
and so if you're tracking net liberty
than a system that functions well
liberates you.
It may have more regulation in it than
the one we currently have,
but that regulation is liberating rather
oppressing and so anyway,
with libertarians,
getting them to imagine to wrap their
minds around the possibility of
regulation that they wouldn't hate.
They're there.
So we are all so experienced now living
in a world of malignant government where
government,
government action almost can't be useful
and so it is natural to rebel against it
and say,
I don't want any more of that.
The less the better because the actions
tend to be predatory,
but that is not the inherent nature of
regulation and so constructing a set of
incentives that caused the market to
deliver you the good parts of what a
phone does without secretly addicting
you to something that you know we now
know.
I mean I don't know how many people in
silicon valley have now issued a note of
caution,
but there are many have switched to flip
phones themselves.
They have,
I mean this is.
This is nature's way of telling you that
these algorithms have escaped our
control.
The fact that the people who are in a
position to make a phone call and no
more or less what the algorithm does,
can't even protect themselves,
ought to.
That ought to set off warning bells for
us.
Right?
Those people are in the best position to
protect themselves and the fact that
they are bending over backwards there
they are externalizing decision making
power.
They're having their secretaries tell
them when they can interact with certain
sites in order to keep them from getting
into habits that they can't manage.
This is,
this is the only warning we're going to
get.
This was bad.
We could still do something about it,
but this is only getting more
sophisticated.
And so if we do want to restructure
things,
and I would argue that even though I'm
market fundamentalists will,
you know,
hear their little sacred sacred thing
being challenged,
what we really want to do is free
markets to do what the brochure says
that they do while eliminating what the
brochure never mentioned.
The brochure.
It doesn't mention the fact that a
totally free market produces predators
and parasites at a huge rate,
right?
It doesn't have to.
We can.
We can structure things such that a
predator is not viable so that it a
predator has nothing to eat and if the
predator has nothing to eat,
the habitat won't have them.
Right?
So that is the perspective that all of
us,
if we would do that,
it's,
this is,
these are abstract ideas,
right?
How would we,
how would we eliminate predators?
Um,
You would eliminate predators by a
disincentive.
So your question actually has a,
a hidden assumption built into it.
You've seen the market as a mature
entity with lots of full grown
predators,
but just as it is with biology,
all of those predators started with
something simple.
And what happened was they tapped into a
niche and because that niche was allowed
to exist,
um,
the predators grow and they get more and
more sophisticated at doing what they
are doing.
If you don't want to see the predators,
you eliminate the niche for predation.
This sounds like it would be functional
with if there was like 100 people.
Well,
first of all,
this is one of the primary questions in
the various conversations where people
are trying to figure out how to
bootstrap such a thing,
is that we have what's called dunbar's
number and numbers.
Numbers basically a limit in the low
hundreds of how many people you can keep
in your head.
Right?
And so the point is we are,
we are adapted to that and that number
is probably an indicator of something
like the number of people that you can
adaptively interact with.
I mean in other words,
if you had,
I mean this was really the motivation
for your question.
If you had 150 people and somebody was a
bad actor,
their reputation would proceed them and
you would,
you would detect I should be careful
interacting with that person so that the
structure would be set up for tribes,
which is essentially how we evolve.
That's what dunbar's number essentially
reveals is that we evolve growing up in
groups of,
you know,
50 to a couple hundred people and those
are the amount of people that you can
keep in your mind.
Right?
So hard drive space.
Essentially we do,
but we also,
human beings are very good at taking a
technological solution and kludging or
hacking a,
a remedy for a problem like that.
So for example,
you on board in your mind have the
ability to track something like 150
individuals with respect to their
reputation so that you know how much to
trust in any given interaction in a
group of,
you know,
1500,
you don't.
On the other hand,
reputation can accumulate in some way
that you can check it through people who
you know,
so people whose reputations are directly
known to you are capable of giving you a
reference and in fact you,
you know that this works because I'm
interpersonally.
If somebody you trusted to a great
extent,
gave you a recommendation of somebody
else,
you would,
you would know how to evaluate it.
So we are unfortunately for for both
better and worse,
we are living in a technological
landscape that doesn't look like
anything that our ancestors faced that
provides mechanisms for building
solutions to problems that in an
ancestral environment would not have
been possible.
And this is not new.
I mean the library at alexandria is a
technological solution to the problem of
Information.
having expanded to a level of the human
mind couldn't hold it and ironically
burned down by ideologues.
Well sure.
I mean that's,
you know.
Yeah.
So you have to build a structure that is
robust to challenge and have all of the
things that would have to be true for a
replacement system,
for,
for planet earth.
The the key is understanding that there
are certain values that all reasonable
people agree on it.
In fact,
you can use to diagnose who's
reasonable.
So assuming that we don't all start at
the same starting point,
right?
Whether it's from our cognitive ability
or education or opportunities,
how would you stop predators?
How would you stop people from preying
on the weak?
How would you stop like.
because there are predators who they
themselves are unfortunate.
Mentally.
They themselves have a deficit of
thinking and we're dealing with such
numbers when we're dealing with 300 and
whatever million people we have in this
country alone.
There's plenty of dummies that you could
pray on.
Well,
the first thing that you would want to
do is you would want to build.
So if you came to me and you said I have
a social network and it provides 85
percent of the functionality of
facebook,
but it insulates you completely from a
dopamine traps being used to it.
Dick dicked you,
I'd sign up in a sec.
Okay.
Right,
right.
But you are an intellectual and you are
rare in that regard that you're worried
about this.
These people that are in silicon valley
that are talking about the dangers of
the things that they've created
themselves.
They're rare.
Most people are like,
look at all the likes,
dislikes.
Well,
but okay,
so there's some sort of bored at work,
right?
In one check their likes.
Yes.
But I mean mike's right,
but pIck,
that's what a lot of it.
You must have a nice butt.
My butt's not bad.
Um,
but the,
uh,
first of all things spread in waves and
you know,
it is possible to just look at the
landscape and say,
well yeah,
only intellectuals are gonna get why
they should want such a thing.
But it's really,
it's not accurate.
I mean,
for one thing,
the world is talking about blockchain
currency.
The world is not talking about
blockchain currency.
A very small percentage of the world is
talk about blockchain currency,
the same amount that it talked about,
the earth being flat.
I don't think that's right,
but I bet it is,
but I would say I grant your point in
that it's not a huge percentage of
people who are talking about blockchain
currency,
but it's enough that on the network news
people are talking about blockchain.
Is it a bubble?
So it is beginning to penetrate the
public consciousness and it is
penetrating it because people have to
navigate lives in which economic
fluctuation jeopardize us them,
and so there's an incentive if there's
something over there.
Blockchain is not a.
It's not a joke anymore.
Do you think that blockchain
people that are involved,
interested in comprehensively understand
what blockchain is?
Are there more or less of them than
people that are in cults?
There are vastly more paying attention
then people in cults.
Well,
what do you have to default?
That's way off because I think there's
like a billion catholics.
Well,
if you're gonna call catholicism.
I grew up in it.
Okay.
A hundred percent.
It's just a coat with a billion people.
Whenever you got a guy who dresses like
a wizard,
he's sitting on a golden throne.
Oh boy.
That's,
that's.
But that is why this is a problem,
is that there's many people that live
their lives by these ridiculous
ideologies that are illogical.
Okay,
so I'm going,
I'm gonna challenge you on this tech
them from predators and facebook likes.
I'm going to challenge you on that.
Swedes do.
Catholicism is not a cult.
What is the difference between a cult?
Here's,
I had a bit for my act.
Let me just make sure a call is bullshit
and it's created by one person and he
knows it's bullshit in a religion.
That guy's dead.
Okay,
so let me.
This is,
boy,
this is rough territory,
but for you.
Okay.
Let's say this is every let's say.
Yeah.
Let's say moses comes down the mountain
with the tablets.
Oh,
that dude.
Okay.
I don't know if moses did come down the
mountain with the tablets.
Don't think he did.
Let's say you did.
Okay.
Um,
did he,
did he know he was bullshitting people?
Well,
do you know
religious scholars?
Actually,
believe in jerusalem,
actually believe that was all about now.
The whole burning bush tell me they
believe in is the acacia butch,
which is rich and dmt,
and they think the metaphor of the
burning bush was actually a psychedelic
experience and that moses during this
psychedelic dmt experience came back
from the other dimension that you go
into when you go into the dmt trance.
With all this
really standard,
the standard messages that I myself have
gotten from these psychedelic
experiences that you have to treat each
other as if we're all one and that our
separations are all illusions.
That you are literally living a life
that if I was born in your body and it
had your genetics,
I would be you and you would be me
because we're all the same and our
differences are really what the Illusion
is when we were these temporary beings
and that negative thinking and negative
feelings and all these things manifest
themselves in negative actions and
negative thoughts.
And you can change that and you can
change the frequency in which you exist
in this world.
Like this is essentially what the 3000
year old version of moses or more than
that moses has tablets were that they
were,
that god was the burning bush.
Perfect.
So can I ask you a question?
You've done some holistic
hallucinogenics oh yeah.
And you've had some insight and that
insight had something to do with
treating people well.
So it definitelY did.
Okay.
Was it true?
Well,
it definitely has benefited me.
True or false.
If you asked me,
is it true that you have had a positive
experiences from psychedelic drugs
where you have interpreted those
experiences and improve your life?
Yes,
that's true.
Okay.
So If you now go and you convey that
thing to somebody who hasn't had the
experience themselves,
is it bullshit?
Well,
here's the thing,
right
about psychedelics as opposed to all the
other ideologies,
is that they're very repeatable.
You don't have to believe in dmt.
If you smoke it,
you're going to experience it whether
you believe in it or
not.
Right.
And actually I think,
I mean,
I am a cautious fan.
I say cautious because I don't think.
I'm not a fan of the idea that these
substances should be used
recreationally.
I think that's a mistake.
I agree with you.
Um,
I think it's fine to have a great time,
but that these things are so powerful
that one should be deliberate about it
and you know,
don't do it with a tv only
about doing it recreationally is,
it's going to get more people to do it
and that if you think it's recreational
and then you do it,
there's going to be a certain percentage
of those people that go.
What was that?
That's not what I thought it was.
I thought it was going in there to have
a good time and I just communicated with
god.
Yep.
Air quotes.
God.
Yeah.
Air quotes.
Well,
but air quotes,
god is marvelous because air quotes god
is the real deal,
right?
In other words,
it's not a dude on a cloud.
It's something,
it is a metaphor for something lodged
very deep in the mind where you can't
find it directly.
And this is a hack that many cultures
have used to access that layer and it's
all very familiar.
Yeah.
To
us.
And when you talk to people that have
studied dmt in particular,
one of the reasons why I think it's so
familiar to us,
when you,
when you have this experience,
one of the first things that happens is
you feel like you've been there before
and they believed that this is because
during rem sleep your brain produces
dmt.
Yep.
It's very difficult to monitor,
but they have been able to through the
cottonwood research foundation,
which all started from the work of dr
rick strassman out of the university of
New Mexico who wrote a book called dmt,
the spirit molecule,
which was one of the very first times
with a dea,
allowed them to do clinical studies on
people with intravenous
dimethyltryptamine,
which is fucking serious shit.
So instead of like this 10 to 15 minute
trip,
You're gone for a long time,
half hour plus and deep deep experiences
that a lot of these people mirrored.
They all had like super similar
experiences.
But through the cottonwood research
foundation,
they found that live rats are producing
dmt in their pineal gland.
this has been proven now,
which was really just speculation.
It was.
There was anecdotal evidence,
but now they know that rats produced
this so they don't know exactly when
people do it because they would have to
do the same thing they do to rats would
have to open your brain up until they
develop some sort of sophisticated
detection methods.
It's just speculation as to when the
brain's producing this incredibly potent
psychedelic drug,
but it's there right now.
It's producing it.
We
know it's produced in the liver.
It's produced in the lungs.
It's endogenous to the human system and
we don't know why.
Yeah,
well,
I'm pretty sure I have a good insight
into why,
but for the moment,
let's pursue the issue of what the
implications are going to hold onto
while cross my fingers.
Cross your fingers on that one.
Um,
the story of just told is perfectly
plausible whether it's 100 percent
accurate or not,
and we don't know,
right?
But thE idea that your mind contains
mechanisms that go into some sort of
psychedelic state without your conscious
mind being able to tap into it.
So your conscious mind walks around
during the day,
not realizing that you're tripping at
some other moments for some purpose.
It's all very interesting.
You're not tripping in your sleeping
mind for no reason at all.
You're doing it for productive reasons,
logically speaking,
it has to be the case that if you're
burning energy and going through the
costly exercise of thinking,
even in the psychedelic way,
that it's happening for a reason.
Right?
And that means that we have carried this
with us from an ancestral state into the
modern state and we now have molecules
that we can trigger it when we want to.
Um,
that gives you access to a style of
thinking that you're telling me has
altered your understanding of your
relationship to other people and that it
metaphorically lines up with what you
often hear delivered in religious terms,
right?
Abstractly,
yes.
RigHt.
And so when you say catholicism is a
cult,
I don't agree because catholicism
historically must have been delivering
messages that caused people to correct
their thinking in ways that made them
collaborate more effectively,
that made them better able to find the
opportunities in their environment.
I'm not advocating that we should sign
up for belief systems that are at odds
with our modern environment,
but one thing we can say I believe for
sure is that religions that have stood
the test of time did so because their
value to the people who believed in
them.
It was so great that those,
that disbelieved were out competed now.
So we get into trouble in the modern
circumstance because we can look at many
of the teachings of any of these ancient
religions and we can compare them to
what we learned scientifically and
detect that there's something not right.
Can I stop you there?
I'm sure scientology.
Is tHat a cult too early to tell?
Okay.
But let's stop.
well,
that whole.
No,
the guy who created it.
Well we do,
but we all have.
So let me drag you back it.
So by the way,
I'm very uncomfortable with scientology
and what it does,
but the problem is,
um,
as scientology itself points out,
if you at the inception of something
like the catholic church,
you might be equally troubled.
Sure.
Which is why I think they're both calls
well,
but let's be careful about that.
So what do you think are cult is?
What do you think you called it?
I cult is the predatory version.
It is tapping into people's natural
tendency to believe in what I call a
metaphorical truths.
And it is using it very often to extract
resources from them to church.
Well,
no,
not like the catholic here at the
catholic church is so long standing and
the population that has.
I guess what I would say is if a
population succeeds by believing in
these things than cult is not the
correct.
Thank you.
And I have different terms.
Were we using different definitions of
the word called done?
But let me.
Let me.
Okay.
Take.
There's a very interesting comparison.
So Joseph Smith,
who started the mormon church had a
turn,
right?
He had a competitor,
uh,
at the time as a book called the kingdom
of mathias,
right about his competitor at the time.
And to me the two looked equally
plausible.
The story that they were selling.
Now,
mathias never had more than 30 followers
and his religion died out and joseph and
Joseph Smith one and in the mormon
church is obviously a real thing.
Um,
but these sets of beliefs are advanced
by somebody,
whether those somebodies are cynical
when they do it or whether they are
earnest.
I think many of these,
the ones that we have that have lasted
for long periods of time have been
advanced by somebody who was in one way
or another,
conscious or not dmt or not tapped into
something that when delivered to other
people actually constituted a kind of
insight now as opposed to being a con
man.
Right?
Okay.
And so,
so the origins of the catholic church
most likely came from some desire for
order and,
uh,
a scaffolding of how to behave and to
give people rules and structure for how
to get through this life with the most
amount of positivity and love.
And by disciplining them and having
these grave punishments being held over
their head,
burning in the fires of the pits of
hell.
If they decide to have sex with another
man or were two different types of cloth
or whatever,
the other silly things that were in the
old testament by doing this,
what they've essentially tried to do was
offer people structure.
No,
it's not really structure.
It is a,
an analog for truths that can't be
spoken.
I'm literally because nobody knows how
to phrase them.
So let's,
let's deal with the church on the one
hand and moses on the other.
Moses is obviously important in,
uh,
in jewish history.
If moses
ate some dmt from the acacia bush,
I think it was smoke and he smells why
the whole thing and the burning bush say
he smoked it and let's say he was super
savvy and farsighted and you know,
obviously he didn't know anything about
molecules that suppose that he had some
ancient model of something and he said,
there must have been something in that
plant that caused crazy things to
happen.
Let's suppose he didn't believe that he
had contacted god or that god had
contacted him.
But you woke up from the thing and was
like,
wait a minute.
I know what these people are doing
wrong.
I'm gonna.
Write it down and tell them came from
god,
but his judaism now a cult.
I think they're all cults.
I think all ideologies are cults.
I just don't.
I don't know.
I don't.
I don't think there is any one person
who wrote,
first of all,
when you're dealing with a christianity,
you're dealing with translations,
right?
Or judaIsm,
you're.
You're dealing with like ancient
translations of languages that aren't
even spoken anymore.
Right,
and you're also dealing with an oral
tradition of who knows how many years
before it was ever bothered to be
written down,
but write,
but written down by people and then
people decide what stays in and what
doesn't.
They changed the rules like the priest
used to be able to marry priests in the
catholic church.
Pope used to have wives.
They ran armies.
I mean,
this is clearly something that human
beings have a hand in manipulating and
changing,
and they do it for the benefit of the
structure itself.
They're not doing it for the benefit of
the human beings that are part of it.
They're doing it for the benefit of the
structure itself.
Oh,
that I don't agree,
but what's what case.
We'll do like the money and the amount
of.
I'm not,
I'm not saying you don't havE corruption
in all of these structures.
You do.
Um,
but I am saying that there is an immune.
This is exactly parallel to what we were
talking about before.
There is the predatory version which I
would call a cult and there is the
earnest version which I would not call a
call now.
I'm very uncomfortable with any of these
things governing policy in the present
because none of them have a literal
relationship with reality that allows
them to deal with the fact that we've
got all these new problems for which
there are no,
there's no religious wisdom.
Maybe there'S a problem in the word
called maYbe,
uh,
maybe we should just say a structure
created by human beings,
which is basically all structures,
all structures,
all,
all models of behavior where you have to
adhere to certain things.
But thE problem with religion and even
with a lot of cults is these supposed
grave consequences for deviated.
Right?
Well,
so alright,
let's,
let's pick up catholicism because it's
easy because so much of the structure is
visible to us.
I would argue that catholicism is going
to be true
of all of christianity.
It's gonna be true of judaism,
but catholicism is.
It is easy to see how it would
facilitate collaboration that
effectively it would recreate in some
sense the insight that you're talking
about from dmt and that it would
instantiate it in the population in a
useful way that would facilitate
collaboration and disrupt processes that
cause infighting springing before.
It might be a structure.
It's the scaffolding for human behavior
and ethics.
Right?
But imagine.
I mean we can see it in catholicism.
Sure.
Know where it is.
So every week you have to go and confess
the shit you're doing wrong to the dude
in the box.
Okay.
That's how they used to spy on you.
I mean that's what that was for.
Well,
but why are they spying on you?
I mean,
no,
they want to make sure that they don't
get overthrown.
Oh,
I don't.
I think.
I think you're too cynical.
Really?
Yeah.
Because what do you think they're doing?
Well,
so first of all,
I'm a biologist.
Okay.
How are these priests who don't marrY
passing on their genes?
They're not.
Oh,
they are.
what are they doing?
This snaky know,
facilitating the stability of the
lineage that they are in charge of.
So the point is they don't pass on their
genes directly.
They're passing on their genes
indirectly through the population.
Their interests are synonymized with the
population that they are,
um,
they are preaching to.
And so you tell the dude in the box,
which we've been doing wrong.
Imagine it's adultery.
Oh god,
I'm,
if I die before next week and I haven't
confessed my adults,
you'd go to hell.
I'm going to go to hell.
That dad had a very unpleasant place.
I'm tell guy it doesn't get to have
someone to tell him.
So now the person I've been committing
adultery with his thinking,
oh shit.
Well I was going to keep this a secret,
but now the priest is going to know that
I've been committing adultery.
They're going to hear from the other
person.
And so I better confess too.
So now the priest has a sense of like,
oh,
there's an adultery problem in the,
in the congregation,
and the priest is,
you know,
flipping through the book and thinking,
oh,
this week,
what should we talk about?
And so,
you know,
the priest then gets up at the pulpit
and uh,
you know,
turn your book to on whatever,
um,
and starts going on about adultery and
the people in the congregation who are
engaged in adultery or thinking,
oh shit,
this is god talking to me directly.
God knows what I've been up to and he's
not happy and that's why we'Re reading
this psalm.
I better cut it,
the fuck out,
right?
So my poInt is,
the dude in the box,
he's taken a vow of poverty.
He's living in the church.
He does well when the town does well.
um,
he,
he's not having babies of his own,
so he can't really get ahead by himself.
He gets ahead genetically speaking when
the town does well and he's in a
position to spot what's going wrong in
the town and he doesn't have a dog in
that fight because he's not involved in
business.
He's not involved in a meeting and,
and being a little salt
relatively recent when it comes to the
catholic church in the last couple of
hundred dollars.
And I would argue if you look back at
any of these traditions,
any of the ones that worked will
successfully have addressed the question
of how you prevent corruption from
emerging apparently was sexual
corruption.
These guys were rock stars.
Like the priests were essentially the
guys who had the direct line to god and
just like professors have been known to
do.
Not you,
but you know,
some have sex with their students
because the students like look at them
like,
oh my god,
I can't believe that professor sitting
down here with my work.
And that's a very minor connection in
comparison to the connection to god.
Anybody who's going to have anybody
who's going to have power is in danger
of abusing it.
Sure.
I would say it's interesting that in the
catholic church and in other traditions
where,
uh,
a marriage and making money are
impossible,
that these appear to be a evolved.
Um,
what's the word?
Uh,
it's like,
um,
error correction or,
or protection from,
from a virus.
So an outbreak of corruption in the
church is a bad thing from the point of
view of the wellbeing of the
congregation and a something that says,
well,
if you're a priest in your spending
money in town,
people are gonna,
look at you funny because you're not
supposed to have money.
And if you're,
you know,
hanging around with cute girls,
people are gonna.
Look at you funny because you're not
supposed to be havIng sex.
Um,
so this limits their ability to get away
with stuff.
I'm not sAying it's zero,
obviously it's not,
but the idea that there will be
protections in,
um,
in each tradition for this,
that religions that don't successfully
protect against abuses of power will
succumb in competition to religions that
do it effectively.
And so you're absolutely correct that
all of the changes in religious texts
that people believe in those,
that's all human beings making decisions
about what to keep and what to throw
out.
And I'm not arguing anything else,
but what I am arguing as those that have
been insightful about what to keep from
the point of view of the particular
problems faced by the population that
they are in,
we'll have a competitive advantage
because they will function more
cohesively than a population of atheists
who doesn't have somebody looking out to
prevent outbreaks of competition inside
the lineage or outbreaks of infighting.
So if you were looking at it in an
objective way,
like say if you were an alien from
another planet that didn't understand
the language and you just observing the
structure,
you would see as error correction,
the structure would say,
oh,
they realized there was an issue here
with power.
And so they error corrected by making
these priests be celibate and then they
figured out a way to keep them from
having money and that'll keep them from
being invested in.
Okay.
Yeah.
I see what you're saying.
And I think it's very misleading to
people who analyze things the way you
and I would because there's so much
hocus pocus associated with these
structures that,
you know,
it's like constantly putting a finger in
the,
in the eye of an analytical person.
Of course.
I mean,
just the way they dress,
right?
I mean just the wearing the wizard
costume and holding the staff and
sitting on the golden throne.
And then all of it.
I mean,
all the pageantry to it.
It's all preposterous.
I mean,
I agree.
Looking at it as a modern person,
it looks preposterous to me.
On the other hand,
there is no way I'm telling you.
I mean,
most of my colleagues,
I'm sure would disagree with this,
but I hope to,
um,
to show them to be wrong on this front,
the,
there is no way that the huge amount of
effort and resource that is invested in
these structures was an error.
Cannot have been an evolutionary error.
Because if it was,
the huge investment that is put into
these structures is an opportunity for
some population that behaves in exactly
the same way.
Except it doesn't make that error to
win,
right,
but when you get power and then you have
the momentum of that power,
I'm overcoming the population and then
you have positions where the behavior
patterns are extremely restrictive and
you have to behave inside these behavior
patterns or there's grave consequences.
I mean,
you could conceivably run that for a
thousand years without any error
correction,
and that's what you've got with islam,
right?
You've got a very ancient form of
religion that michael shermer wrote a
piece about it that's pretty interesting
where he was talking about how it's the
only religion that didn't go through the
enlightenment and he makes these
comparisons to like the corrections that
have been had with other religions as
time has gone on that haven't happened
there,
and you could equate it to resource
management.
You could equate it to the part of the
world in which they live.
You could equate it.
There's a lot of different ways that you
could try to figure out why this
happened,
but the reality is that that thing has
not changed.
That structure has not changed for a
long time.
I think you've hit on exactly the right
point.
M islams mechanism for preventing
outbreaks of chain parasitism was to,
to hard code the thing,
and this is a tragedy because it,
what it means is that where islam needs
to update it doesn't have the mechanism
for doing it,
so,
uh,
but also has a built in way to keep
people aboard.
Like if you become an apostate that
you're allowed,
you can kill them.
Right?
And kill apostates which is,
there is no other religion that we have
right now that operates like,
that has draconian imagines of
scientology.
Did that,
right?
Well,
I mean scientology obviously has a huge
number of completely unacceptable
mechanisms to keep people from leaving,
but,
but how is that not a cult since it was
created by a science fiction writer
literally
out of nowhere.
I'm going to be horrified if I said it
wasn't too early to tell.
So how is that possible?
Okay.
So that could be
benefits in the future.
If scientology continues to evolve and
self self-correct,
it could get to the point where it's a
behavior pattern that could be
complimentary and perhaps even
beneficial to people.
I do not believe that this is where it
is headed.
But if a thousand years from now it had
flourished and the population that
believed these things was successfully
growing,
you'd have to say,
well,
there's something in that set of
beliefs.
It's working for these.
Um,
so anyway,
I'm not arguing that it isn't the
called.
It has lots of hallmarks that make me
think
I'm troubled by including much like
mormonism.
You know,
the guy who made it,
but this,
unlike mormonism,
which was an 1820,
we have video,
we see l,
ron hubbard,
bad teeth,
and his fucking captain's outfit on with
a metals that he gave himself.
You're like,
hey,
what is this?
Right.
Oh,
right.
you get a planet when you die,
or
something like that.
It sounds like a cult to me.
On the other hand,
you know,
I mean,
we've got the mormons get a planet when
you're.
Sorry scientologists don't get a planet.
No,
no.
The mormons do.
And it was one of the osman brothers
albums,
they all went to these planets.
Like in the album,
I forget what the album is.
It's a hilarious album.
But if you open it up,
it's all planets.
And the album,
the name of the album is this concept
that you get a planet when you die
to me,
because the universe is so big,
we can each afforded.
That's the plan.
That's it.
See that?
That is some joseph smith's shit,
by the way.
It's a wonderful book.
If you,
if you read the,
the actual origins of mormonism people
that are listening to go,
wait a minute,
what do they believe?
Wow.
They believe some wacky stuff.
But uh,
he,
uh,
he had a golden or a seer stone rather
that allowed him to read the golden
tablets.
The seer stone was a special magic rock
that allowed him to read these golden
tablets that contained the last work of
jesus.
Is that the inside of the album with
other planets?
So I,
I believe he was actually illiterate.
And that was a con man.
He was murdered,
put a sheet over his head and dictated
what he was supposedly reading to
somebody else.
That's my understanding of it.
But,
um,
it was a charismatic person,
but many people have created cults.
He was,
I think what they did right?
Mormons are some of the nicest people
I've ever met.
They have an amazing sense of community.
They're super nice and I've always said
that if I was going to join a cult,
I think I joined the mormons,
but where they fucked up is they
regulations came in,
they started restricting the market.
They started,
the regulators came in and stop these
people from having nine wives and then
they're not going to be so nice anymore.
The reason why they were so nice is
because they have these crazy
relationships.
There were having orgies every night at
nine people living in the house.
Then they allowed to have sex with.
It was a problem with your day because
for everybody who had nine wives,
they were eight dudes who had not.
Those guys got to get their shit
together and start their own call on gas
where you know,
well,
maybe they are gay.
I don't know.
Um,
what about the women too,
right?
How about a woman who has 10 husbands?
You know,
this is bullshit for her.
That doesn't happen.
yeah,
it should right now be possible.
No.
See there's a really good biological
reason.
It doesn't make any sense,
but you already.
Oh man,
don't,
don't go polyandrous on me.
He went,
we went way far away from our original
point,
which was,
um,
that you could figure out a way to
restructure with this.
Uh,
I don't want to call it plan b because
that's the abortion
game.
Be.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Well,
I don't want to say it.
There is no game b at the moment.
What?
There is a conversation that emerged
from this and the basic point is that
one constructure a superior deal to what
people are able to work out for
themselves and it can function inside of
the system and it can gain adherence for
the very same reason that people are
buying bitcoin for the same reason that
people have decided to get smartphones
for the same reason people have signed
up for facebook.
Those are,
with the exception of bitcoin.
Those are game examples and they are
predatory.
But you could provide a version that was
not predatory,
that would function in a superior way
with respect to how,
uh,
how it enhanced your ability to function
in the world and rational people.
I mean,
you know,
you make a good point.
It's not that we have billions of people
who are sophisticated enough to know
that they should be looking for that
alternative and who will jump on it.
But to the extent that you have people
that are sophisticated,
are aware that their lives are being
disrupted by forces.
That they're incapable of managing like
these dopamine traps and the like,
uh,
who will embrace these technologies?
Because they themselves are looking for
a mechanism to insulate from the
predatory things that have emerged in
the market.
What You will get is the spread of these
technologies and if there's one sort of
key message here about all of the
objections that one might raise about
the difficulty of creating such
alternatives and getting them to be
adopted,
the number of things that we have
already adopted because we got something
for her cell phone being the perfect
example.
We didn't have to tell people to get a
cell phone.
People got a cell phone because of all
the things that they could see that it
did for them.
And that same drive to pick up some new
technology or agreement because it
enhances your life.
It solves some problem for you in some
way that's good.
That causes the thing to be adopted out
of self interest and that,
that is what the mechanism for change is
going to have to look like.
His self interest causing people to
embrace a shift in the,
uh,
the opportunities and obligations that
they're signed up for.
Now,
I think one of the problems that I have
with this is that,
uh,
I always assumed that this is going to
be like on january the first we're
switching over to the new system,
but it's not right.
Can't be camp,
can't be a ba.
It's got to be almost like a natural
chain of events or it has to be like
water flowing down hill.
that.
So I can speak scientifically about my
own field because,
you know,
I,
I did enough training that I,
I know where the bodies are buried.
When you're in a field and that field is
stuck,
it is impossible to move the field.
You can't get a hearing that will allow
you to change the way the field thinks.
But you can step outside the field.
You can leave the reservation as it
were,
and you can proceed by other means.
And what,
what happens is the same thing that you
know,
lars anderson discovered with archery,
is that once you're no longer signed up
for what good form looks like,
there are all kinds of ways to
accomplish things that are not
documented.
And so finding those alternatives,
gay may is not serving people's needs.
We are all unhealthy,
you know,
even if we find a way to be physically
healthy,
we are all overwhelmed by so much social
noise and so much a choice that is
meaningless that we end up wasting a
huge fraction of our time spending a
tremendous amount of our mental effort
on puzzles that aren't interesting or
worthwhile or productive.
and so we are all,
each of us has a giant opportunity to
upgrade our lives by simply removing a
bunch of the noise by getting the
systems that are supposed to function in
our interest to do so more effectively.
And therefore we are a,
I hate to use the word consumers,
but we would be willing consumers for a
better alternative or to show up for us
and presenting that alternative so that
people find it,
they experiment with it.
And upon discovering that actually,
you know what,
I am better off when I participate in
this way than that way that that causes
adoption.
And it doesn't take very many.
You know,
bitcoin obviously started with,
you know,
an ambitious person who set the thing in
motion,
what's the currency with only one person
using it,
right?
But now it's not a currency with one
person using it.
It's a currency.
You've used it.
I've used it.
Um,
so anyway,
it is possible to get adoption based on
the fact that the thing solves problems
that people are otherwise stuck with.
Do you think that because things are
moving so quickly today,
it seems to me that like new ideas are
implemented so fast.
New concepts are accepted so quickly
that something like this where it
might've taken several decades,
a few decades ago,
would only take a few years today.
Well,
the,
there it become a thing.
There are two things.
One,
there is the possibility that things
will change very rapidly and then there
is the fact that they must,
because the trajectory we're on,
we are playing with such powerful
technologies and being operated at such
a high rate with such high throughput
that um,
those of us who have started,
you know,
I think it's a mistake to look at the
problems of the world as individual
problems.
It's much more effective to look at them
as symptoms of problems that don't have
names.
So we have an economic system that
generates technologies that create great
benefits in the short term at some
massive cost in the long term.
And we have no mechanism.
Once they've generated massive profits,
there's no ability to shut them off,
right?
That's a problem that has many,
many symptoms that we could name,
but um,
that we,
we in effect don't have much time.
That the rate at which we are
liquidating the wellbeing of the planet
at present is so fast that effectively
we need,
we need to change quickly.
And It doesn't mean.
I guess that's the other thing that I
haven't said yet is nobody including me
thinks that we're going to be able to
spell out an answer in the present that
is correct,
but what we can do is navigate in the
direction of the answer that is correct
and we can discover what that answer
looks like.
In other words,
the right model is not the writing down
of the new rules of the world and the
embrace of them because you get
benefits.
It is prototyping what the new structure
would be and then you institute the
prototype and some group of people who
have signed up for it and then you
discover what you didn't know about it
that you needed to know and you correct
those problems so that what you get is
effectively evolution.
Building an elegant solution rather than
what progressives often accidentally
invite,
which is good intentions that produce
horrifying outcomes because you didn't
know what they were actually going to do
once you set them in motion.
Right?
Communism being a great example,
you think communism is going to solve
the problems of the world.
In fact,
it creates,
you know,
massive harm and kills millions because
you didn't understand what it would do
in motion.
So we don't want to ever face that
again.
We don't want to be utopians.
Anytime you engage in utopianism,
if you set it in motion and you're going
to create a dystopia,
it's virtually guaranteed.
The way to avoid that is not to imagine
that,
you know,
the answer gets to define what objective
you want the system to reach and then
navigate towards it.
Um,
how do you think this could be
implemented?
Well,
uh,
it requires capital frankly,
and it requires capital and people who
understand what the problems are.
Most importantly,
it requires people who understand game
theory because what we keep doing is
setting systems in motion that have the
characteristics that guarantee
evolution.
There are only four of them.
And if you set a system in motion that
has those four characteristics,
you will get adaptive evolution and what
it will produce.
You have no control over it.
It will produce whatever the niche space
allows.
Um,
so you need people who are aware of the
game theoretic parameters of the space.
And who understand,
essentially the game theory is a very
important topic.
It's less complicated than people think.
There aren't as many games as you would
imagine.
There are a few canonical ones and then
there a bunch of variations on a theme,
but understanding those things so that
you can use so you can effectively
harness the power of evolution to build
a functional system rather than build a
system and then suffer the consequences
of evolution that you didn't anticipate.
That's what we keep doing.
We built an economY and a political
system that evolve out from under us and
they create monstrous phenomena that we
didn't anticipate because they weren't
in the plan.
Do you think that it's possible that you
see the radical change?
The social change has happened just over
the last couple months since the harvey
weinstein.
You see what's happened?
I mean it literally is probably stop
sexual harassment dead in his tracks.
Women who work in these workplaces that
had to deal with the consequences of
these guys,
the amount of those sexual harassment
episodes is probably been radically
reduced like that.
Yeah.
Is it temporary though?
I don't know.
It's a good question.
I think because my only concern is that
with false accusations or overreactions
or people that are just not treating
this like the incredibly powerful medium
that it is the medium for change and
then using it to their own benefit,
people could get greedy and corrupt
this.
Right.
But I think it's already happening.
Sure.
I'm sure what,
you know,
examples.
Yeah.
A couple of them.
I mean,
I don't want to.
I'm like every other man,
I am hesitant to put my weight on the
ice with anybody because who knows what
you don't know.
Right.
But I've seen several stories now that I
find very disturbing.
The first one,
and I must say,
you know,
this was a topic of conversation with me
and my friends is I'm guessing it would
have been with you and your friends and
uh,
I feel weird saying this on your
podcast,
but herod comes,
my friends and I have discussed this,
had a kind of reaction which was,
you know,
it turns out to have been a really good
decision never to grope anybody who
wasn't into it.
Right,
right,
right.
Of course,
it wasn't the reason that we didn't grow
up anybody,
but um,
but nonetheless it turns out to have
been a benefit that we don't,
we're not worried about what's gonna
emerge.
Yes.
So that's what I was saying.
And then I saw this garrison keillor
story.
Yeah.
And suddenly I didn't feel so safe
anymore because it's in keilor.
One is the most disturbing one.
It's not actually,
but it's not.
No,
there's one more.
There's a worse one.
Tell everybody that garrison keillor
story story.
So by the way,
the only thing we have,
so he was fired from a Minnesota public
radio is radio program was not only
renamed but the old ones were
disappeared.
And mind you,
I don't give a damn about garrison
keillor's radio program.
Right.
But the only thing we have as an
explanation is his own account.
Right.
So is there another side of the story?
I can't say,
but I must say the account had the ring
of truth to it because it would have
been very devastating if some compelling
counter narrative that emerged.
And the story he told was that he had
been comforting a woman.
I think she may have lost somebody.
He had been comforting a woman and he
had leaned in,
I guess to hug her and put his hand on
her back and he said to her shirt was
open and he touched her back and he said
his hand went up about six inches that
she recoiled.
He apologized in the moment.
He then sent her an email apologizing.
She said,
don't worry about it.
It's not a big deal.
And he said that he and she were
friendly until he got a contact from her
lawyers and how long after the event was
the.
Didn't say,
but my feeling is let's take the worst
possible interpretation,
the least generous to keilor
interpretation of this.
Groped her a little bit.
Yeah.
Maybe he lost his place.
Maybe just leaned in.
He leaned in for a moment.
He had a sexual thought or something.
You touched her back and then you know,
he did what he should've done,
which just apologized.
She accepted the apology.
He still felt bad about it.
He apologized again.
And so anyways,
just a back.
Right.
It's just batching.
So yeah.
I'm not saying zero in the story,
but the idea that the guy's entire
career is being erased from the radio
archives because of this one story.
If there's more,
there's more,
But if there ain't more,
that's really disturbing.
This would not have happened if it
wasn't for like harvey weinstein,
harvey weinstein,
who's his actions were so disgusting and
so egregious and so numerous,
so despicable that it went so far this
way that anything even remotely gross
got shifted into that category.
Like into the kevin spacey category.
Kevin spacey's grabbing dixon
for now until our story came out on the
same day of the garrison keillor story
and that one is truly disturbing too.
I mean really just,
you know,
rape presumably legally,
but even if it wasn't what is described,
and again,
you know,
I'm a believer in due process.
I thought I just had affairs.
No,
no,
no.
There's really disturbing stuff
including him.
I mean,
I want to be a little cautious about
this business,
about him having a button under.
They all have buttons.
That's a really common thing.
And nbc it is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
See,
that's the problem with these chrome,
with the story,
but also it's not something you really
want to go into and start reading.
You feel like you're gross is gross,
but I will say there was one story
whether that button is a commonplace
thing that's been misinterpreted.
I don't know,
but there is some story in which some
woman came into his office,
he had her bend over his desk,
he had sex with her,
she fainted and he had his assistant
take her to the hospital,
which,
you know.
Anyway,
yeah,
I now,
because I can't establish that any of
this stuff is true,
but I will say that killer story doesn't
sound like the loudest or it doesn't
sound like the harvey weinstein story.
Uh,
or kevin spacey
like al franken.
One,
one of the women said that he grabbed
her waist,
he squoze the fat around her waist when
and she was disturbed because even her
husband is not allowed to touch her like
that in public.
Well,
I want to come back to al franken
separately.
I believe we need a very separate
category for franken.
But,
um,
I was going to tell you what was worse
than the keeler story.
Go ahead.
So the killer story is disturbing.
When I heard that one,
suddenly my feeling of safety based on
the fact that I haven't grown up to
anybody who didn't want to be groped,
vanished because suddenly it was open
season.
Um,
but the story that disturbs me even more
is the matt taibbi story.
I don't know who that is.
I know who matt tilapia.
So matt taibbi rolling stone reporter
who's been really excellent at
confronting power,
especially in the financial sector and
you know,
he's been very consistent on this,
apparently is a young man.
He was in Russia and he was publishing
satirical magazine,
I guess it was,
and the sotiro satirical magazine.
so there's the story that came out,
which was that he had written all of
these things about,
uh,
about assaulting women and mocking them.
It turned out he didn't do the writing.
He wAs his partner and that he and his
partner were engaged in producing the
satirical publication that was in fact
mocking the culture of americans who had
gone over to Russia and were snort and
tons of coke and a living it up as they
were corrupting the society that had
recently been freed from communism.
And so the.
The point is,
this was a case in which the evidence
against type ab was ironic because it
was really tight eeb critiquing this bad
behavior amongst other men and so the
reason that this,
you know,
I wouldn't know what to make of that
story except that the person,
the journalist who started sorting this
out interviewed both matt taibbi,
his girlfriend who worked at the
publication and other women in the
office soliciting stories about what had
happened in the office and the women in
the office universally reported these
guys were honorable and they weren't
behaving this way.
And this was all about a satire of these
bad folks.
And so anyway,
there's a way in which this story creeps
me out beyond any other.
Because the danger of losing.
You know,
matt taibbi.
There isn't another one in what he's
doing is important and he's amazing.
He's a brilliant writer.
Right.
And so,
you know,
I was a going to be pretty surprised if
he was behaving this way,
but okay.
I've been surprised by a few of these
and it wasn't even necessarily behaving.
It was writing,
it was writing,
but the fact that there's no,
they're there when you pursue the story.
There's no women who were in a position
to say,
yeah,
actually he was kind of a dick said,
right.
He didn't write it.
It was designed to lampoon people who
were behaving badly in this context,
in exactly the way that the me too
movement should applaud.
You
tweeted and quoted a woman who wrote
something and I retweeted it as well
when you did it,
which she said,
here's an unpopular opinion.
I'm actually not at all concerned about
men who are falsely accused of sexual
assault slash harassment.
And you said,
rethink this.
You know,
there's the idea that honorable men who
are on your side could get caught up in
this and you're not even remotely
concerned.
Uh,
I don't know if you follow the thread
before she turned her page too private,
but one of the more hilarious things,
they turned it on her saying,
what about men of color who are falsely
accused and know we're not men of color?
Why she felt the racism coming her way
and Immediately acquiesced it was,
it was fascinating because I'm watching
the social dance,
this weird peacocking of morals and it's
just,
it's so odd.
But I think that it's just
like we're talking about what other
things systems correct themselves.
You find this,
this one terrible example,
and then everything sort of like it gets
washed out because of this one terrible
example.
And then I feel like it'll settle,
you know?
I don't know.
I'm just guessing you're the biologist.
I do.
I'm disturbed that particular tweet
you're talking about about,
I don't care if some innocent men go
down,
is based on one relatively easy to
understand,
concluded,
but it misses the more important one.
So what she's effectively saying is
there's been a ton of carnage.
Lots of women have suffered awful stuff
at the hands of men who weren't
accountable.
And so a few men who suffer some bad
stuff is tiny in comparison.
We all get that,
but that's a terrible idea because it's
a team thing then is them.
It's the worst idea because what you
want is a system in which men are
honorable and if you allow men who are
honorable to be skewered,
simply because some person often cynIcal
decides to go after them.
A,
you're going to eliminate all of the
courageous men from the system because
all those people have enemies.
And so the point is,
anybody with an enemy suddenly has to
fear an accusation that has no truth in
it,
that's going to be reflexively believed.
So if you want the system to work,
the last thing you want to do is just
decide it's fine for innocent people to
go down with the ship.
Yeah.
And to not have any respect for due
process is just crazy.
I mean,
that's what you're going to go back to
the mccarthy era.
You're going to go to the salem witch
trials.
It is that,
it is that.
It is that.
Yeah.
Um,
I just hope it keeps our daughters and
wives and girlfriends and mom's from
being groped at work,
right?
I mean it might,
it might look the,
I've always said this,
the environment of an office is so
fucking entirely unnatural that it takes
incredible restraint just to key people
from behaving in the way that they would
if they were surrounded by these people
on a regular basis.
And like we were talking about before
with professors,
the relationship that a professor has
with the student,
but it's even more so with a boss and an
employee,
right?
a secretary,
someone who makes a fraction of what you
make or someone who's under,
you know,
the below you in the office food chain
and you kind of can dictate whether or
not they do well in life.
Whether or not they advance your input
can change the course of their career,
how much money they make,
whether there'll be able to go on
vacations,
whether they can live comfortably pursue
their dreams.
Well,
I mean it's a crazy environment.
The office environment is a very bizarre
environment.
It's super dangerous.
And what I keep waiting for,
maybe somebody who's written it and I
haven't read it yet,
but the,
the deep question.
So we have to deal with the issue of men
behaving this way.
Obviously it's completely unacceptable.
And you know,
we have two dangers.
We've got
people cynically wielding these
accusations and we also have,
um,
predatory behavior,
crucifying people for infractions that
don't amount to,
you know,
the same tragedy,
right?
So anyway,
um,
so those issues are important.
But what I want to see is that what
happened is actually a consequence of an
unhealthy truth of our system.
It actually goes back to the
conversation we were having before where
the power of men like harvey weinstein
and matt lauer comes from a very
unnatural concentration of opportunity.
So women have been compromised because
if you're in the news business at was at
nbc and matt lauer tells you to open
your blouse,
suddenly you're staring at a major
career decision,
right?
Do you say no?
Or do you say yes?
And that's one person is not supposed to
have that much power.
You should be able to walk out of nbc
and say,
I'm not working there anymore because
matt lauer's and ass and go somewhere
else,
but if matt lauer is not only has the
power to make a or well to make your
career,
but he also has the power to break you
because you can't,
you can't endure.
Having said no to him,
then that's a tragedy.
And in fact,
did you read the selma high x story on
harvey weinstein?
Terrifying.
terrifying.
And I thought,
I mean a.
I thought it was very courageous of her
to write it,
that she didn't need to because
weinstein was already understood to be
the monster today was.
And I actually thought she did a good
job.
I mean he is a monster,
but she went.
She,
even though he was her monster,
in her words,
she said that there were two harvey
weinstein's and you didn't know which
one you were going to get.
So she actually,
she dealt with the part of him that
wasn't this way apparently honorably
enough to say that when nobody else was
talking about.
So I don't wish to resurrect anything rv
weinstein here.
I think the guy is getting what he
deserves and even though due process is
super important in this case,
there's so many stories that it's
impossible to imagine.
Well,
it's not just stories,
it's actually written into his contract
and the settlements,
but the sexual harassment clauses in his
contract with the craziest things I've
ever seen in my life.
Like they literally said,
if you have one infraction,
it's this amount of money to
infractions.
It's half a million dollars,
three infractions monetized.
It's insane.
And the point is while there's something
unhealthy about a system that creates
somebody so powerful that they are
capable of just treating their own
sexual assault of other people as a cost
of doing business by writing it into the
contract.
so w w we have to fix.
Not only do we hAve to fix that.
If you're a man and you behaved this
way,
you're not safe.
We also have to fix the system that let
this go on so long by concentrating
opportunity so that any person who
decided to say,
hey,
actually things are not healthy here
would have been a not listened to
because everybody else had stuff to lose
if harvey weinstein didn't like ya.
Um,
and so anyway,
curing the concentration of opportunity.
Problem is part and parcel of solving
the sexual
assault problem.
Yeah.
And it's also this giant enterPrise.
Right?
And when you have one person who's the
king,
which is essentially what he was,
they behave like kings have classically.
I mean,
that's what kings do.
They,
they,
they want everyone they want.
You know what I mean?
You hear horrible stories throughout
history of things that men do when they
have ultimate power.
The old phrase ultimate power corrupts
absolute power corrupts.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's just,
there's no way around it.
It seems like in less there's full
disclosure and less.
I firmly believe that all of this is.
There's two things going going on right
now that we are in sort of an adolescent
stage of human evolution in terms of our
culture that we're working out,
how we Interact and behave with each
other.
That information and the ability to
exchange information is highlighting all
these flaws and these natural systems
that we have with these alpha chimps
that are running these giant groups.
Um,
but then I think this technology is that
it's exposing us is going to give way to
something that's even scarier.
And my number one fear over the last
year has been artificial intelligence.
Oh,
I'm tremendously troubled by it.
I'm more scared of it every day.
Every day I wake up thinking,
are we just sleeping while this thing is
about to go live?
And we literally are in a fucking
terminator movie.
I think it's both better and worse than
that.
We,
it's happening already.
And because it's not robots,
we don't see it.
Right.
It's happening in your phone.
It's your,
it's your phone.
Yeah.
And the thing is,
it's a tie.
It's not a gi,
right?
So age being general.
Okay.
So the fear,
the one that we have sentient,
yeah,
that the thing is smart enough to start
thinking on its own and that it might
come up with its own,
be creative,
it might be creative and either
misunder,
you know the paperclip problem is you
tell it to make as many paperclips as
possible and it sees your attempt to
turn it off or reprogram it as an
obstacle to making paperclips and it
just starts to liquidating the universe.
So that's not a malevolent ai.
That's a confused ai.
Malevolent ai is also possible,
but what we've got is a baby version.
The algorithms causing us to become
addicted to our phones and to do damage
to our lives is ai.
These algorithms that are developing,
I mean frankly it doesn't even matter
whether People are reprogramming them or
whether they are reprogramming
themselves and it is undoubtedly a
mixture.
What we have is a evolutionary system
that the winner will be the site that
manages to capture your attention in the
face of competitors who are tryIng to do
the same thing and they will build
anything and everything into that
algorithm to get you to do it,
which means there's nothing in your life
that sacred right.
Your life can be liquidated to get you
addicted to that side on the phone.
What we have now is a case where the
algorithms aren't so good that we can't
have this conversation,
recognize that this is a danger we've
created for ourselves and address it.
we could address it now,
but if we don't realize that the phone
algorithm addiction problem is,
this is the warning shot,
this is the place where we get a chance
to recognize where we're headed and deal
with it before it's agi.
If we don't do that,
I don't.
EveryBody who's serious and has thought
about this question has had the same,
oh shit.
rational conclusion is that we.
There's no stopping this.
There's.
we can rationally debate how far off it
is,
but once it gets going,
there's essentially no good.
there's no good way out,
so there's no one that's going to agree
to stop right now.
Right?
It's too much competition involved in.
In terms of the the you have.
there's so many resources that are on on
so much resources.
There's so much power.
There's so much money on the line to see
who can come up with the best version of
this and do it the quickest and it's
this mad race towards the edge of a
cliff and no one exactly knows whether
or not we're going to be able to use the
brakes.
Right,
and so in some ways I think this is the
the ultimate demonstration of where we
are and what we must contemplate in
order to save ourselves.
Because if we can agree that the ai
problem has the potential to destroy us
and that given time,
it will have the power to destroy us and
that we are vague at best on what
mechanisms might prevent it from doing
so.
But then we've got this loophole which
is well as oppose.
You took 99 percent of the ai projects
and manage to correctly build in some
algorithm that prevented them from going
rogue in one way or the other,
but somebody else decides not to.
So we have to confront this at the level
of what is allowed.
Right.
I don't like hearing myself say that
because I hear people turning off on the
other end when they hear,
oh,
he doesn't want to allow us to innovate,
but for the survival of the species,
I think it's imperative.
We have.
We have about.
We have no choice and so scared that
we're caught up in all this other
nonsense and we're thinking about so
much stupid shit and our life like you
know,
whether or not kim and kanye stay
together and in the middle of all this,
there's a lab right now and they're
connecting
these wires and connecting these dots
and reprogramming and accelerating the
evolution of this thing and it's not
going to turn off and that life as we
know it,
we will only have a few layers left to
this.
I really feel like we're in a fucking
science fiction movie and we're at the
beginning of the movie where
everything's great.
We got problems,
we got a lot of dudes out there pinch
and butts and some.
Some dudes are pretty rapey and we got
rid of the kevin spacey,
got taken out of that movie.
We're doing pretty good and then in the
meanwhile there's fucking robots that
are being built by boss dynamic that
does back flips and they're gonna be
able to think for themselves and they're
going to have machine guns for hands and
their body's going to be filled with
bullets.
What could go wrong?
It'S fucking crazy because it's
happening at such an accelerated rate
that it's literally what I'm.
I'll be sitting around,
I'll be playing with my kids,
I'll be hanging out and I'll be like,
fuck.
Are they making robots right now?
Is that.
Are we.
Are we like a year away from this being
a real problem?
Well this is.
this is kinda what I'm getting at.
Is that the ai problem?
In some ways,
maybe it's good because it's causing us
to be able to focus on one of these
hazards to us that you,
you can't.
Once you've seen why this was a risk,
once you've really made eye contact with
it,
you can't talk yourself into why it's
safe,
right?
Because it can't possibly be right.
And if 99 percent of them are safe,
one percent is enough to create the
problem.
So once you've,
once you've got that information,
you can then begin to extrapolate to all
of the other problems that don't have
the same,
um,
the same intrigue around them.
You know,
there's something sam harris makes the
point that as you talk about the,
you know,
the ai apocalypse,
it is simultaneously horrifying but kind
of fun to,
to get into because,
you know,
because it is sort of scifi and all,
but the whole landscape that we have
built,
right?
Our sociopolitical landscape was built
by people who had never heard of
darwinists.
There was no darwinism.
they didn't know.
And so they Built a bunch of ecosystems
in which stuff evolves and they didn't
know to worry about it.
So the ai problem is a very concentrated
version of a very general problem,
which is if you build a habitat and you
install into it those features which
caused evolution to occur,
it will occur and what it will create is
entirely a question of what the niches
look like that you have left open.
So we are living that we are suffering
the consequence of an economic
environment that is evolutionary,
that creates a giant rent seeking
monsters who are liquidating our
wellbeing and putting it into their bank
accounts and we've created a political
apparatus that has the same
characteristics and now we're facing a
robot version that actually has the
potential to very rapidly push us over
the cliff.
My real issue with this,
and this is something
that I've been battling again with for a
couple of years now,
is that the.
This is what we do and it's one of the
reasons why we're so fascinated with
technological innovation.
I mean they literally.
We are the caterpillar that is becoming
the electronic butterfly and we don't
realize it while we're doing it and
we're so obsessed with the newest,
latest,
greatest phone that really doesn't
change your life at all.
Like,
I got this new iphone.
It's pretty.
It's great.
I eat do the same shit I did in my old
iphone,
but I was so pumped to get it,
man.
But you're in some ways facilitating the
evolution of this technology that will
ultimately lead.
If you follow it to an end point,
it's going to lead to something very,
very bizarre.
I mean,
if you're ray kurzweil,
you think it's going to be wonderful and
you've got to be able to download your
brain into a computer,
but if you were a lot of other people,
you think it's an absolutely terrifying
thing that's going to eventually lead to
us being irrelevant
and this is unnecessary.
So likely we won't have time to go very
far into it,
but we have an alternative and I think
it does look a little bit like lars
anderson with his fancy archery,
you know,
which is we are just on the cusp of
understanding enough about what a human
being is and how it functions for us to
actually take control of our structure
and to turn it to our,
to basically creating a stable non
utopian abundant system.
In other words,
the stuff that we are all pursuing,
right?
You've got your first smartphone and it
changed everything and it was marvelous.
And then your second one didn't change
that much in your third one was no big
deal on your fourth one is barely a
blip.
Right?
Um,
that thing that we are pursuing,
the wellbeing that we felt the burst of
when we got our first,
our first smart phones,
that thing can be made to.
The system can be made such that we are
constantly getting the signals of
wellbeing and the liberty to do things
that are of consequence.
In other words,
it is not beyond our current
understanding to build a system that
instead of getting you to innovate
something,
having a huge burst of dopamine and then
it wears out and you're constantly
looking for the next one.
It is possible to build a system that,
um,
is structured such that your intuitive
interaction with it is healthy so that
you are feeling about that is something
I want to engage with.
That is something I don't feel like
engaging with actually leads you
correctly through it.
And that would free your mind to think
about interesting things rather than
thinking about,
you know,
which news magazine is the least fake,
right?
So I'm architecting a system that is,
that understands what a human being is
that understands we are not built to be
happy and therefore pursuing happiness
as if we were built to be happy is a
hazard.
We should be pursuing something else And
we should recognize that happiness is a
carrot on a stick.
That,
that evolution built into us in order to
get us to pursue objectives which were
not stable wellbeing.
They were actually the spread of our
genomes,
which you can attach to technology.
This pursuit of happiness is the pursuit
of material possessions and we
facilitate that with these
advertisements that make every new thing
look like this is the one that's going
to take me over the top.
I'm going to finally reach the promised
land.
Well,
we.
Technology is one thing really.
We are built to pursue a something that
economists called growth,
but I would say human beings like all
creatures are built to detect
opportunities that they can capitalize
on and those opportunities can look like
various different things.
It can look like a bunch of,
you know,
for some creature foraging,
it can be some food that it happens
onto.
For a population of humans that can be a
new continent.
That's a huge opportunity for human
beings.
It can also be a new technology that
takes whatever opportunity you have and
make.
It allows you to do more with it.
But we are wired to search for those
things and the pursuit of those things
has produced a great many marvelous
innovations and discoveries,
but the fact that we do not understand
that we are mindlessly pursuing these
things,
even when they are not available causes
us to do all sorts of harm to ourselves.
So understanding these things as We
finally are beginning to,
we could buIld a civilization that did
not leave us on the hedonic treadmill,
pursuing happiness which cannot possibly
be reached,
but would allow us to be fulfilled and
to to utilize the amazing brain capacity
that evolution has given us for
something that's actually worthy of it.
Bret weinstein on that note,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Alright.
Thank you sir.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I hope.
I hope someone can actually do this.
I hope it can be done.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Alright.
Thank you bret weinstein on twitter and
you don't have
but those other things and don't use
those other terrible technology.